et d'avoir répondu à notre invitation je
tiens tout d'abord à remercier le le
président larcher
qui a accepté d'ouvrir cette audition à
l'ensemble des commissions du sénat
merci à lui de nous avoir permis
effectivement à nos collègues d'être
de pouvoir se joindre je sais qu'il ya
il ya les réunions commission il ya bien
sûr des sujets importants mais merci à
celles et ceux qui ont pu mieux nous
rejoindre je vais excuser la sénatrice
martin berthet
le sénateur en guerre
madame delattre et jocelyne 10 days est
également je dois excuses et ronan
dantec
qui vient de m'envoyer un sms je vais
vous dire ce qui m'a dit
bonjour jean françois impossible d'être
présents ce matin je préside en
parallèle une réunion de l'ornais que me
demandez pas ce que ça veut dire j'en
sais rien
sur l'adaptation au changement
climatique ça c'est la suite mais je ne
sais pas peut pas vous détailler ce
qu'il en est mais donc il préside une
commission bien mes chers collègues nous
sommes très heureux et honoré de
recevoir aujourd'hui plusieurs experts
français ayant participé aux travaux du
groupe d'experts intergouvernemental sur
l'evolution qui met du climat le giec
nous avons déjà eu la chance
d'accueillir des experts du giec le 6
octobre dernier pour une présentation
passionnante des conclusions du groupe
de travail numéro 1 consacrée aux
aspects scientifiques du système
climatique et du changement climatique
la réunion du jour portera sur les
conclusions du groupe numéro 2 portant
sur les impacts du changement climatique
ainsi que sur les enjeux d'adaptation et
de vulnérabilité et sur les conclusions
du groupe numéro 3 qui aborde les
scénarios de baisse à réduction des gaz
à effet de serre pour limiter le
changement climatique autrement dit les
moyens d'action le rapport du groupe
numéro un elle fait le constat de la
hausse continue des gaz à effet de serre
et de l'intensification des événements
climatiques extrêmes depuis la période
pré hier les deux derniers tomes ne
laisse aucun doute nous devons agir et
agir aujourd'hui et de manière très
déterminée au sein de tous les secteurs
si nous voulons limiter le réchauffement
climatique de la planète à 35 degrés
centigrades nous devons par ailleurs
mieux nous adapter au réchauffement
actuel et à venir et à ses conséquences
pour aborder ensemble ces sujets nous
accueillons aujourd'hui madame valérie
masson-delmotte coprésident du groupe de
travail numéro un que nous avions déjà
reçu en octobre c'est un plaisir même de
vous entendre à nouveau je vous remercie
au nom de mes collègues de votre
disponibilité
monsieur conneries le cozannet du bureau
de recherches géologiques et ministère
le brgm spécialiste des enjeux liés à la
montée du niveau de la mer auteur
principal du chapitre europe du groupe
numéro de madame nadia mazouzi des mines
paristech spécialiste de l'énergie et de
la modélisation prospective auteur
principal du chapitre demande et
services du groupe numéro 3 madame anna
maria lamelles directrice recherche à
l'université paris 8
cette réunion s'inscrit pleinement dans
le cadre des travaux de notre commission
d'élaboration et de contrôle des
politiques publiques de réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
d'adaptation aux effets du dérèglement
climatique ainsi que de suivi des
négociations climatiques internationales
notamment dans le cadre de la prochaine
scop 27 toutefois compte tenu du
caractère transversal et structurelle
des enjeux soulevés par la transition
écologique elle est exceptionnellement
ouverte à tous les sénateurs avant de
vous laisser la parole j'aimerais
souligner que les rapports du giec ne se
contente pas de nous présenter l'état
des lieux de la connaissance
scientifique aussi vous analyse se
veulent des analyses pertinentes
politiquement mais non
prescriptive selon l'expression
régulièrement un style est utilisé dans
vos publications je tiens à vous dire ou
non de mes collègues que nous apprécions
particulièrement votre attention
constante à trouver le ton juste tendant
à présenter de manière rigoureuse et
accessible les connaissances actuelles
faisant l'objet d'un consensus
scientifique plaît et r nous sommes
conscients de la difficulté de la tâche
qui est la vôtre celle d'éclairer les
décideurs sans se substituer à eux c'est
pourquoi nous vous remercions de vous
prêter à nouveau à cet exercice exercice
qui n'est pas aisé et je vous laisse
donc madame la présidente
masson-delmotte la parole
bonjour et merci beaucoup monsieur le
président de cette invitation à nouveau
à partager les points clés des des
rapports récente du giec donc ce que je
voudrais faire c'est d'abord comme point
de départ vous rappeler les points clés
du rapport du groupe 1 du giec qui avait
fait l'objet d'une audition le 6 octobre
et puis ensuite rappelé la masse de
travail considérable qui est derrière
chacun des rapports des groupes 2 et 3
et nous aurons ensuite une présentation
des points clés par donc trois des
auteurs français de ces rapports il ya
eu 15 scientifiques qui travaillent en
france qui ont contribué au rapport des
groupes 2 et 3 alors donc sur
le premier aspect que je voulais
mentionner donc les points clés qui
avait été présenté à l'audition du 6
octobre souligne à quel point
l'évolution à venir du climat dépend des
décisions que nous prenons maintenant
donc nous vivons avec des changements
généralisée rapide et qui s'intensifie
sans précédent depuis des milliers
d'années l' influence humaine sur le
réchauffement planétaire qui atteint sur
la dernière décennie 1,1 degré et sans
équivoque c'est un fait scientifique
établie cette influence humaine sur le
climat par les rejets de gaz à effet de
serre notamment rend plus fréquents et
plus sévère des événements extrêmes
comme les vagues de chaleur on l'a vu
récemment les plus extrêmes ainsi que
les sécheresses dans de nombreuses
régions chaque région de la terre est
affecté de multiples manières des
tendances des extrêmes des événements et
ses changements s'accentuera avec chaque
incréments de réchauffement
supplémentaire
certains aspects comme la montée du
niveau de la mer du fait du temps de
réponse des glaciers de l'océan profond
du groenland ou de l'antarctique sont
irréversibles mais peuvent être ralentis
et d'autres changements qui dépendent
direct du niveau de réchauffement
planétaire peuvent être arrêtés si l'on
parvient à limiter ce réchauffement
planétaire
à moins d'une réduction immédiate rapide
et à grande échelle des émissions le
ghana est clair limiter le réchauffement
à un niveau proche de 1 degré et demi
sera impossible on va atteindre ce
niveau de réchauffement dans les
prochains 20 ans en moyenne sur 20 ans
et pour limiter le réchauffement
planétaire vraiment d'un point de vue de
la physique du climat il est bien sûr
nécessaire de réduire fortement et
rapidement les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre notamment le dioxyde de carbone
et le méthane est une des conditions
clés pour limiter le réchauffement est
d'atteindre des émissions mondiales de
co2 qui soit 1 est zéro donc je
maintenant je passe en aux rapports des
groupes 2 et 3 du giec je décris le
rapport du groupe 2 comme vivre avec les
conséquences d'un climat qui change
agir pour gérer les risques et donc agir
face aux conséquences de ce
réchauffement est le groupe iii comme
agir sur les causes de ce réchauffement
et les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
donc le rapport du groupe 2 c'est le
travail de 270 chercheuses et chercheurs
de 67 pays avec 675 contributeurs qui
ont passé en revue les éléments probants
de 34000 publications scientifiques
c'est un rapport qui a été relu comme
toujours à plusieurs reprises par la
communauté scientifique et les experts
nommés par les gouvernements plus de
soixante deux mille commentaires pris en
compte et le résumé à l'intention des
décideurs a fait l'objet d'une
approbation pendant deux semaines au
mois de février très constructive et ce
sont ces points clés qui vont être
présentés tout de suite en ce qui
concerne le rapport portant sur
l'atténuation donc la réduction des
rejets de gaz à effet de serre ses 278
chercheuses et chercheurs de 65 pays 354
contributeurs près de 18000 publications
scientifiques examiner et environ 59
mille commentaires de relecture
l'approbation de ce rapport a été une
des plus difficiles que j'ai vu pendant
deux semaines à nouveau virtuellement
donc un rapport publié le 4 avril
extrêmement tendue notamment par rapport
à des questions d'équité vis-à-vis
l'action par rapport aux changements
climatiques les comptes rendus de ces
sessions d'approbation sont disponibles
y compris en français par des
observateurs extérieurs et donc j'ai mis
les liens si vous souhaitez les examiner
de manière approfondie
donc on va passer à la partie groupe 2
les points clés je vais les résumer
brièvement avant de donner donner la
parole à gonnery et ana maria donc le
changement climatique c'est une menace
pour le bien-être humain et la santé
planétaire c'est un rapport qui souligne
les interdépendances avec l'état des
écosystèmes et le bien-être humain donc
l'action d'adaptation monte en puissance
mais avec des progrès qui sont non et
inégaux et des décalages entre les
besoins et ce qui est réellement mises
en oeuvre malgré les efforts
d'adaptation on observe des impacts
généralisée et grave qui entraîne une
dégradation des écosystèmes et qui
affectent la vie de milliards de
personnes
pour les prochains 20 ans quand le
niveau de réchauffement atteindre un
degré et demi les impacts vont dépendre
des actions qui sont mises en oeuvre
maintenant en par anticipation en
matière d'adaptation
les impacts et risques sont de plus en
plus complexes difficiles à gérer pour
certains irréversible notamment la perte
de biodiversité et vont s'intensifier
pour chaque incrément supplémentaire de
réchauffement donc on note un décalage
croissant entre les besoins d'adaptation
et les actions réellement mises en
oeuvre en particulier pour les personnes
les communautés les régions les plus
vulnérables
les options qui existent pour réduire
les risques faisable et efficace perdent
en efficacité avec l'augmentation du
réchauffement et donc nous sommes devant
une brève en fenêtre d'opportunité pour
construire un développement qui soit
résilient vis-à-vis du changement
climatique et soutenable donc je vais
laisser la parole à gonnery anna-maria
peut-être vous voulez vous mettre ici ce
sera plus simple merci
merci de votre invitation donc je vais
commencer la présentation pour le groupe
2 voilà donc j'ai contribué au rapport
sur l'europe et la méditerranée et à une
synthèse sur les conséquences de
l'élévation au niveau de la mer et puis
anna maria lamelle a contribué au
chapitre 17 sur les délais la prise de
décision alors voilà le en fait une
figure qui se maquille qui résume le qui
résume en fait l'objet du rapport du
rappeur du groupe 2 en fait l'objet du
rapport de groupe de ce n'est pas
seulement l'augmentation des aléas donc
le fait que les vagues de chaleur
augmente que les ressources en eau sont
moins accessibles qu on a davantage
d'inondations du fait des plus intenses
et de l'élévation niveau de la mer et
tous les impacts en cascade qui résulte
de ces de ses conséquences comme par
exemple les feux de forêt
c'est également en fait la vulnérabilité
notre vulnérabilité la vulnérabilité des
écosystèmes et leurs expositions donc la
vulnérabilité des personnes dans le
rapport du giec vous voyez que entre 3 3
et 3 6 milliards de personnes vivent
dans des contextes hautement vulnérable
ce qui signifie qu'ils ont un accès qui
est aléatoire à des infrastructures de
base qui ici par exemple en france
permet de s'adapter dans de meilleures
conditions comme par exemple accès à des
systèmes de santé
concernant les la biodiversité nous
avons leurs apports de l'ip et b e s qui
le giec de la biodiversité qui est paru
en 2019 qui montrent que 25 % des
espèces de la plupart des groupes
d'animaux et de végétaux étudiés sont
déjà menacés d'extinction en raison de
l'occupation des sols de prélèvements
directs tels que la pêche par exemple de
la pollution et des espèces invasives et
donc en plus se rajoute le changement
climatique par dessus cette c4 cause
d'extinction qui sont observés par l'ip
et b e s notre exposition elle est
également en croissance c'est la
pression sur les terres l'expansion
urbaine et la réponse que nous faisons
elle est en retard c'est à dire
l'adaptation nous observons que
l'adaptation est en retard par rapport à
ce qui serait nécessaire pour limiter
les risques qu'est ce que c'est les
retards d'adaptation ainsi un exemple
très concret une ville qui aujourd'hui
aurait tardé à s'attaquer au problème de
l'îlot de chaleur urbain par exemple
dans ce végétal is an et bien c'est des
conditions de vie plus difficile pour
les habitants pendant
pendant pendant les vagues de chaleur
qui sont de plus en plus fréquentes on a
également de la malade habitations donc
typiquement deux exemples la
climatisation individuellement c'est une
solution collectivement c'est une
demande en énergie qui est trop forte un
autre exemple la construction de
l'infrastructure sur la côte si vous
n'avez pas de sédiments pour pour
maintenir les plages ou d'un moment en
fait vous avez des cookies qui augmente
considérablement pour le maintien de ses
infrastructures
on a des problèmes de financement et des
limites à l'adaptation de type de
limites des limites dur c'est à dire
impossible de s'adapter au delà d'un
certain seuil et d'émilie des limites on
va dire soft qui sont qu' aujourd'hui
par exemple on pourrait imaginer
s'adapter davantage mais il y à des
barrières tels que par exemple
sociale institutionnelle ou de
gouvernance qui font qu'on ne s'adaptent
pas
tellement
donc là en fait c'est une figure qui est
dans le résumé pour le deal pour les
décideurs qui essaient de synthétiser
tous ces risques qui sont extrêmement
variés donc vous voyez à gauche les
l'augmentation des températures en noir
c'est l'augmentation des températures
observée les 1,1 degré due au
réchauffement climatique dû aux
activités humaines qui avait présenté
valérie et puis du bleu au rouge les
différents scénarios d'émissions de gaz
à effet de serre avec une stabilisation
en deçà de 2 degrés pour les deux
scénarios bleus et puis à une comptine
continuer à émettre des émissions de gaz
à effet serre pour les rouges donc vous
avez 5 raison d'inquiétudes qui sont
précisés ici la première c'est alors je
pense qu'on voit ma souris oui c'est des
systèmes qui sont uniques et menacé donc
typiquement les coraux entre 1 degré 5
et 2 degrés se joue finalement là
c'était l'avenir des coraux on perd 99 %
de la couverture corallienne adoré et en
fait là les coraux ses 25 % de la
biodiversité marine qui qu'ils abritent
actuellement un autre exemple de système
unique menacée c'est par exemple la
biodiversité marine en méditerranée ou
alors toutes les communautés qui
dépendent des glaciers de montagne en
termes de ressources en eau
le deuxième raison c'est donc là vous
voyez que là il ya vraiment des limites
qui sont déjà atteintes en fait un des
limites
on est à un degré 1 lorsque vous passez
dans le violet on atteint les limites à
l'adaptation les limites du rpt à
l'adaptation et aujourd'hui on est déjà
dans une situation qui est inquiétante
par rapport à cela avec des risques des
impacts importants qui sont observées
pour les pour les le deuxième risque en
fait c'est des extrêmes de chaleur et
notamment les extrêmes de chaleur et de
pluie avec des conséquences très
importantes pour la santé des gens donc
notamment pendant les canicules en fait
les risques de coup de chaleur les
risques cardiovasculaires etc
la troisième risque c'est la
distribution des impacts certaines zones
soient extrêmement exposées aux
changements climatiques donc typiquement
les zones arctiques la méditerranée donc
ce sont des autres qui verront en
premier des impacts du changement
climatique en méditerranée par exemple
jan il ya une alerte sur les questions
de sécheresse et de ressources en eau
entre autres
après c'est le quatrième c'est
l'agrégation des impacts dont
typiquement pour le cottier si vous
regardez individuellement sur certaines
zones on peut imaginer s'adapter à
l'élévation du niveau de la mer jusqu'à
un certain point jusqu'à peut-être en
stabilisant le l'élévation au niveau de
la mer à 4 millimètres par an mais ont
l'ensemble des dommages que l'on calcule
lorsqu'on les agrège à l'échelle
mondiale sont tellement considérables
qu'on peut se poser des questions sur
les ressources en énergie en matériaux
qui permettrait de s'adapter l'élévation
niveau de la mer et enfin le cinquième
risque c'est des événements singuliers
donc typiquement la possibilité d'un
effondrement de l'antarctique qui serait
lié au fait que
entre le 20e et le 22ème siècle on peut
pas exclure aujourd'hui que le
réchauffement des eaux cause des
désordres c'est annick en fait cause un
une fonte retrait rapide de
l'antarctique dont vous voyez en fait
que on a des risques climatiques on
constate également qu'ils sont de plus
en plus complexes et difficiles à gérer
et on voit que certains changements sont
irréversibles alors là c'est sur la
biodiversité
donc le même système en fait de
représentation des risques avec en blanc
une situation qui n'est pas altérée par
le changement climatique en jaune on
voit déjà des effets considérables en
rouge on voit des risques majeurs qui
commencent à arriver et en violet on
atteint les limites de l'adaptation est
donc vous voyez à nouveau cette question
sur les les coraux avec des limites durs
qui sont atteintes déjà aujourd'hui en
fait et des questions également sur la
mortalité des arbres sur les pertes de
budgets vers cité l'augmentation des
feux de forêt tout ce qui est en fait
biodiversité marine etc
alors lorsqu'on fait le bilan en fait de
quelles sont les solutions la plupart
des mesures d'adaptation favorise le
bien-être et les objectifs de
développement durable on a une liste des
mesures d'adaptation ici qui sont qui
représente un grand nombre de secteurs
ça peut être le cottier la ville
l'agroécologie le fait de considérer
l'agriculture et l'écologie
les systèmes énergétiques et puis des
mesures qui s'adapte un petit peu
partout en fait les questions de santé
de gestion des risques de gouvernance
etc de services climatiques
cette figure ce qu'elle montre c'est
dans quelle mesure est ce que c'est
chacune de ces mesures d'adaptation est
compatible et renforce l'objectif des
les objectifs de développement durable
donc la réduction de la pauvreté la
réduction de la faim une meilleure
éducation un accès à l'eau qu'ils soient
assurés etc et on voit en fait que la
plupart des mesures ont des effets
positifs
certaines ne l'ont pas en fait c'est la
fameuse malle adaptation est par exemple
pour le cottier cet exemple que lorsqu
on s'adapte en côtier en construisant
des digues
cela peut se faire au détriment des
écosystèmes côtiers parce qu on les
détruit tout simplement voilà mais on
voit quand même que beaucoup de mesures
ont des effets positifs pour l'atteinte
des objectifs de développement durable
c'est donc un message important du
rapport c'est qu'en fait il est possible
de vivre en 2050 à 10 milliards
d'habitants en ayant atteint les
objectifs de développement durable en
ayant limité le changement climatique à
un degré 5 ans n'ayant en s'étant
adaptée à ses conséquences qui seront
déjà perceptibles plus importante
aujourd'hui est en fait en ayant réduit
les pertes de biodiversité
et là je vais passer
anna-maria en disant en fait
qu'effectivement on a fait également une
évaluation de la faisabilité et de
l'efficacité de ses mesures d'adaptation
alors cette cette efficacité faisabilité
de des mesures d'adaptation se dégrade
au delà de un degré 5 mais on voit qu'il
ya quand même beaucoup d'options qui
sont faisable efficace jusqu'à 1 degré 5
je vais laisser la parole anna maria
bon alors je vais continuer en ce qui
concerne le rapport de groupe 2 j'ai
travaillé dans le chapitre ii dans une
chapelle de synthèse qui concerne la
prise de décisions pour gérer les
risques et donc nous avons réuni tous
les données des chapitres sectorielle et
aussi des chapitres régional et on a
essayé d'identifier les différentes
risque de base des clés risques et caen
sont des options d'adaptation
ici je ne peux pas entrer en détail mais
vous pouvez voir que
ces options d'adaptation sont diverses
par exemple si on imagine que la
situation va s'aggraver et on a vu tout
à l'heure que presque
4 milliards de personnes vit dans les
réseaux région de risque ont dit ce
qu'ils indiquent aussi de migration vous
voyez ici la dernière disque c'est quand
ça justement la migration qui peut être
saisonnière qui peut être
intergouvernementale mais aussi peut
être
permanent donc en fait ça déjà ici nous
avons nous pouvons voir qu'il y à une
fois mme de
l'adaptation transformative
voilà donc nous avons opté pour une
gestion itérative des risques
nous avons vu que d'une côté nous avons
un
certain nombre de risques qui ne
concerne pas simplement
l'augmentation de la température des
océans mais aussi
les risques liés à la manque de
nourriture à
dans des situations de conflit armé et
c'est donc
alors les décideurs on a mis dans notre
modèle au milieu les décideurs les
décideurs viralement sondés peuvent être
évidemment les politiciennes ou les
députés ou des sénateurs
mais aussi les individus les
organisations
et ceux qui passent ici ce que vous
voyez c'est une modèle assez classique
de management des risques mais on peut
voir que il ya des feedbacks ça veut
dire que chaque fois on ne peut pas dans
cette situation d'incertitude qui a le
changement climatique définir un projet
et se tenir puisque ulises événement
tant tour dans l'environnement dans le
système terrestre comme dans le système
lui même peuvent charger et finalement
c'est décisions peuvent
ne peuvent pas réduire les risques voire
seulement
le risque peuvent même cloître où
peuvent se transformer et qui vont la
voir aussi le concept de risque résiduel
c'est extrêmement important même si on
prend une très bonne décision parce
qu'on peut construire un mur pour se
protéger de la montée des océans
ça ne marche pas en plus à détruire
l'écosystème donc il faut retourner
ça peut retourner
vers claire et créer de nouveaux risques
donc il faut opter pour une
gestion de risques itératif
donc un tout à l'heure valérie elle a
dit aussi
que donne notre rapport on a mis
l'accent sur l'importance de la
baisse de la santé du système
écosystèmes et vous voyez sur cette
image d'une côté on a les
bénéfices qui coïncide qui
sont liées à la bénéfice de la
renforcement de l'écosystème et d'autres
côtés vous voyez que à partir de
l'analyse de la littérature évidemment
nous avons pu voir que
en fonction des différentes
interactions entre les deux systèmes
il y a des meilleures solutions et
notamment par exemple la restauration de
la nature la restauration de la nature
permet
aussi de assainir le système
écosystèmes
et aussi
peut être très bénéfique pour la
l'humanité et curieusement
on n'a pas attendu cette résultats mais
finalement la
la gestion de la nourriture
et cet élément extrêmement important
aussi la consommation le type de
consommation qu'est ce qu'on va manger
comment on va manger
autant pour les écosystèmes que pour
pour la la l'humanité
bon j'aurais pu encore évidemment
continuer à parler beaucoup mais donc
pour cette message de notre
chapitre le changement climatique est
une menace vitale pour l'homme et les
écosystèmes
plus nous attendons plus les
opportunités nos écharpes et le rapport
propose des solutions
nous savons que le rapport c'est à peu
près mille quatre cents pages donc mais
on a essayé de vous montrer ici quelques
éléments
merci
monsieur le président est ce que vous
souhaitez enchaîné sur les points clés
du rapport du groupe 3 oui très bien
donc je pense que vous avez bien noté
dans cette présentation pour la partie
au risque et adaptation les quatre
risques clés qui ont été soulignés pour
l'europe de l'ouest qui sont la chaleur
extrême les effets pour la santé et les
écosystèmes le risque de pénurie d'eau
d'abord en méditerranée puis ensuite à
des latitudes plus au nord le risque
pour les rendements agricoles et les
risques multiples liés aux inondations
en fait un pluviales fluvial et côtières
les enjeux d'adaptation mais aussi leurs
limites et par mille adaptation je pense
l'accent qui a été mis sur les solutions
dites fondée sur la nature pour avoir de
multiples dimensions de soutenabilité
dans les réponses qui sont apportées
donc si l'on passe à la partie
atténuation les points clés du rapport
du groupe iii du giec pour moi montre
l'ampleur des leviers d'action qui sont
disponibles et qui permettent d'agir
maintenant pour réduire massivement les
rejets de gaz à effet de serre donc la
situation elle est complexe au sens où
nadia va montrer que les émissions
mondiales de gaz à effet de serre ont
été records sur la dernière décennie
mais en même temps il y à une montée en
puissance de l'action pour le climat et
des leviers d'action qui sont abordables
faisable est disponible dans tous les
secteurs d'activité donc que ce soit sur
les modes de production mais aussi en
agissant sur la demande et qui si toutes
ces options sont déployés pourrait
permettre de réduire de moitié dans le
monde les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre d'ici à 2030 c'est un rapport qui
souligne également à quel point les
prochaines années seront critiques pas
uniquement pour engager vraiment une
adaptation plus transformative mais
aussi pour réduire massivement les
rejets de gaz à effet de serre et sans
une action de ce type forte sur cette
décennie limiter le réchauffement à un
niveau proche de 1 degré et demi sera
hors de portée et l'atteinte de
l'objectif de limiter le réchauffement
largement 2° sera menacée et le dernier
point c'est que l'accélération de
l'action pour le climat en tenant compte
de l'équité donc à la fois pour réduire
les rejets de gaz à effet de serre mais
pour renforcer l'adaptation ce rapport
souligne également à quel point c'est
essentiel pour un développement
soutenable donc je laisse la parole à
nadia
alors donc vous l'avez compris notre
travail se décline en trois temps donc
le temps de la compréhension des
phénomènes le temps de l'évaluation de
l'impact qu'ils ont sur nous et puis là
l'idée du troisième rapport c'est est ce
qu'on pourrait quand même limiter
l'ampleur de ces phénomènes en essayant
de réduire les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre et donc pour bien travailler il
faut savoir de quoi on parle donc une
première partie du rapport est dédiée à
l'évaluation de l'évolution en fait de
ses émissions de gaz à effet de serre à
travers donc des mesures et là je
voudrais souligner le fait qu' il est
souvent très complexes de mesurer ces
éléments et puis vous le verrez aussi à
travers des scénarios qui sont des
scénarios illustratif et ça c'est un
point aussi que j'aimerais bien
préciser pour que ça soit clair pour
vous donc
la dernière décennie a vu croître de
manière
phénoménale et en moyenne annuelle les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre au
niveau mondial
donc on parle beaucoup du co2 puisque
vous le voyez en bleu c'est la partie la
plus importante
mais d'autres
et du co2 pardon qui vient des
industries enfin des du fossile
essentiellement mais il ya d'autres
sources d'émissions comme donc l'usagé
des sols en jaune et puis vous avez les
émissions de méthane
les
oxydes d'azoté et puis il ya une chose
aussi importante c'est que les gaz
fluorés qui était en diminution se sont
remis à croître donc globalement les
nouvelles sont quand même assez mauvaise
et le paradoxe c'est que on peut noter
dans énormément de périmètre ce qu'on
appelle les actions pour le climat ce
qui fait parler à tout le monde de la
fameuse transition dans laquelle nous
serions
malheureusement il n'en est rien donc
malgré ce nombre de bonnes intentions va
dire qu'ils sont l'inscription d'un
nombre croissant d'entreprises de ville
de région avec une ambition de zéro
carbone
malgré le fait que plus de 50 pays est
inscrit dans leurs lois des plans sur le
climat comme le nôtre on constate cette
croissance est donc c'est ce paradoxe
qu'il faut résoudre et c'est ce paradoxe
je pense sur lequel il faut absolument
réfléchir pour mettre en place des
solutions de manière rapide alors les
éléments au delà de ses intentions c'est
que il ya eu un déploiement aussi de
technologies on a vu les coûts de
certaines technologies dites bas carbone
diminuer énormément et finalement leur
permettre de se répandre là vous avez
quelques graf alors bon c'est vrai que
les graphes on voulait mais vous en avez
beaucoup là j'imagine que cette voie
c'est à titre illustratif on pourra
revenir dessus
donc ça c'est pour l'éolien et pour le
solaire et puis il ya aussi un élément
dans l'équation qui est un petit peu
complexe c'est le fait que si on cumule
tous les investissements actuels
existant au niveau des énergies fossiles
que ce soit pour produire de
l'électricité ou pour un usage dans
l'industrie et qu'on ajoute tout ce qui
est prévu en fait c'est bon on a déjà
épuisé notre budget carbone par rapport
à cette ambition de rester dans une
limitation des deux degrés d'accord donc
ça ce sont des faits et encore une fois
nous sommes là que pour énoncer des
faits alors en parallèle de 5 est ce
qu'on peut voir pour le futur et c'est
également l'objet de ce travail autour
de la scénarisation donc là je voudrais
préciser que ces scénarios sont des
scénarios illustratif en tout cas pour
celui enfin oui ils sont tous
illustratif c'est à dire que les
chercheurs ne se prétendent pas être des
liseurs de boule de cristal mais il
essaye d'intégrer les éléments dont ils
disposent pour voir quelle est la
tendance vers laquelle nous
nous
positionnons donc ceux d'en haut
les scénarios en rouge ce sont les
scénarios qui disent où nous emmène la
tendance étant donné les politiques
existantes aujourd'hui
alors il ya un petit problème c'est que
en réalité elles ne sont déjà pas
aligner vous voyez le petit gap ici en
rouge avec ce que les états se sont
engagés à faire en termes de
nbc c'est à dire contributions
nationales
d'accord les engagements à 2030 2050
dans le cadre des cop notamment et puis
le deuxième petit problème c'est que par
rapport à ce qu'on devrait faire pour
vraiment être en ligne avec ses ambition
de ne pas subir l'impact du
réchauffement trop fort donc au en
dessous de deux degrés et éventuels
mieux en dessous de 1 au niveau du 1° 5
vous voyez qu'on en est très loin donc à
oui alors la chose ici que je voulais
vous dire c'est que au moment de la
sortie de ce rapport l' agence
france-presse dans la demi-heure qui a
suivi la conférence de presse a prétendu
qu'il nous restait trois ans pour agir
c'était une très forte mais
compréhension du message en fait il nous
reste absolument pas trois ans pour agir
on est déjà en retard par rapport à
l'action mais ça a été en fait l'idée
qu' il nous faudrait trois ans pour
inverser et atteindre le pic enfin
redescendre à partir du pic c'est plutôt
ça le message qui était donné par les
scénarios qui sont devant vous et moi
j'aimerais que vous le résumé à va en
fait il fallait symétrie hier donc
aujourd'hui il est grand temps
alors maintenant ça c'était pour le
constat est au niveau donc de ce que
nous pouvons évaluer en termes de
solutions telles qu'elles sont proposées
par la connaissance scientifique ce que
fait le rapport c'est qu'il se promène à
travers un certain nombre de secteurs
que j'ai reproduit ici donc le secteur
de l'énergie le secteur de l' usage d un
usage des sols l'industrie les bâtiments
les villes les transports
les la demande et les services à je vais
revenir là dessus en fait ça veut dire
que parmi les dix sept chapitres vous en
avez enfin les premiers sons sur
l'évaluation de ces émissions et de
cette évolution que j'ai décrite et les
suivants sont sûres qu'est ce qui se
passe dans tous ces secteurs comment on
peut implémenter des solutions et quels
sont les potentiels qui permettent de
réduire en fait ces émissions je vais
pas tous les passés en revue parce qu'on
n'a pas le temps et donc j'ai choisi de
parler d'abord des terres non pardon des
terres de l'énergie
et l'énergie juste en précisant aussi
que ça doit pas être le seul sujet qui
nous accapare parce que très souvent
quand on parle du climat des émissions
on parle de l'énergie et après on se met
à
se focaliser sur deux technologies de
type de technologie ou en général on
n'est pas d'accord et ça fait beaucoup
de polémiques donc le message le message
là pour le pour la question de l'énergie
s'est en fait il faut une transition
majeure et massive vers des technologies
des carbonnais est une des pistes et
l'électrification mais attention dans la
mesure où l'électricité produite est une
électricité bas carbone ce qui au prisme
de notre
lieu d'habitation peut paraître évident
mais qui n'est absolument pas le cas sur
toute la planète donc ça c'est un vrai
sujet de
d'attention qu'il faut apporter à ça et
ensuite il ya effectivement des
carburants alternatifs qui eux mêmes
doivent être issus d'une
énergie décarbonée donc on parle de
l'hydrogène mais si l'hydrogène n'est
pas vert ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens
le deuxième secteur qui est un secteur
important par rapport aux sujets
français l'émission des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre c'est le secteur des
transports donc dans la continuité de
cette idée de l'électrification il y a
effectivement avec les mêmes réserves
que celle que je vient d'émettre une
potentialité de shift et vers des modes
de transport électrifiée et de tous
types c'est à dire au delà du véhicule
électrique
il ya la question du transport par
train et du fret et donc de la
substitution de certains certaines
technologies et puis il ya aussi un gros
potentiel par rapport à la réduction en
fait de la demande et ça on va y revenir
dans le travail qu'on a fait
spécifiquement sur la demande
donc ça c'est le chapitre dans lequel
j'étais investi celui sur la demande et
je voudrais faire une remarque
importante il me semble c'est à dire que
c'est la première fois dans ce rapport
qu un chapitre sur la demande alors je
vais explicité parce que c'est peut-être
en jargon scientifique a été proposé et
dans le cadre de la coordination entre
les gouvernements et les scientifiques
ça a paru important ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire essayer d'évaluer en fait les
potentiels de réduction des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre non pas par rapport
à l'offre mais par rapport aux usages et
par rapport aux services qui sont rondes
et dont nous exprimons finalement le
besoin donc le chiffre que nous avons pu
évaluer en cumulant tous les éléments
qui permettrait donc de réduire les
émissions
dues à changement de nos usages et à une
modification de notre demande sont de 40
à 70 % des émissions qui pourrait être
réduite à l'horizon 2050
alors deux remarques d'abord il ya une
marge d'erreur qui est quand même assez
importante entre 40 et 70 % c'est pas la
même chose et en plus derrière il ya des
conditions qui sont extrêmement fortes
c'est à dire que ça c'est à la condition
que les politiques
soient mises en place les politiques
d'accompagnement que les infrastructures
soient disponibles et que les
technologies
soit également
accessibles pour mieux expliquer si on
imagine qu'on va changer de mode de vie
en modifiant notre mobilité il faut
encore qu'on ait d'autres modes de
substitution qui soient offerts si je
suis obligé de prendre ma voiture pour
aller au travail et que je suis en rase
campagne
je ne peux pas changer mon comportement
en termes de transport il me faut un
tram
ddd bus électrique enfin peu importe
mais il faut que j'aie un moyen de
substitution donc ça c'est vraiment
l'idée qu' il ya une vision du système à
avoir et il est très compliqué de
stigmatiser les comportements si on
n'offre pas la possibilité
de l'échanger étant donné
l'environnement dans lequel on est
donc je pense qu'on pourra peut-être
reparler des différents éléments alors
les plus évidents par rapport à sa basse
et alors on a on a on a classifié ça en
trois en trois niveaux de réflexion
void shift in cloud ça veut dire que
d'abord il ya tout ce qu'on peut
complètement évité et là il est clair
que on a un impact direct sur l'arrêt du
sont des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre exemple je
me déplace ou alors je ne bouge pas bon
bah si je ne bouge pas à ce moment là il
ya plus de problème effectivement je ne
je ne je n'utilise pas un véhicule qui
potentiellement et mi6 le deuxième
niveau c'est shift ça veut dire je
change en fait mon mât technologie pour
réaliser
mon usage donc je continue à avoir la
même demande est en fait je fais de la
substitution
donc je vais pas reprendre l'exemple du
transport je rentrais dans quelque chose
d'un peu polémique qui est l'exemple de
l'alimentation donc on a eu du mal et ça
je peux faire ce commentaire à avoir
puisque nous sommes basés sur des
connaissances scientifiques à avoir une
évaluation vraiment de
le menu carnet on va dire donc la
consommation de viande parce que c'est
très dépendants en fait du type
d'élevage que vous avez et puis il ya
quelque chose à laquelle il faut faire
attention c'est à dire que certaines
régions de la planète où c'est l'apport
de protéines principal il n'y a pas de
substitution possible mais disons que si
on est dans un endroit où il est évident
que si on ne fait pas de recours à la
viande on évite un élevage intensif qui
va être extrêmement émissifs à ce moment
là on va substituer notre alimentation à
un régime qui doit être lui-même
protéiné mais dans ce régime protéiné il
faut avoir également à l'esprit que si
c'est pour aller consommer des éléments
qui viennent de l'autre côté de la
planète
et que donc on va avoir un bilan carbone
équivalent à celui qu'on est en train
d'éviter à ce moment là on a on a à
revendre voilà on a décalé le problème
donc quand on dit shift ça veut dire se
décaler mais vers des choses qui ont du
sens par rapport à un autre à notre
préoccupation est le deuxième le
troisième élément j'ai dit in cloud ça
veut dire améliorer et donc ça c'est
recourir à des technologies qui pour
nous servir dans la même demie nous
devons être plus efficace c'est-à-dire
des meilleurs chauffage en termes
d'efficacité
une meilleure isolation dans les
bâtiments qui vous permettent de
continuer à avoir un certain bien-être
alors la dernière chose qui est très
importante c'est qu'on a discuté dans le
cadre de ce chapitre donc où il y avait
beaucoup de sociologues de psychologues
de scientifiques de ces disciplines
c'est le problème de qu'est ce que c'est
que le besoin est qu'est ce que c'est
qu'un niveau de vie décent on a parlé d'
équité et il se trouve que sur la
planète et c'est bien l'objet de tout
c'est bien toute la difficulté en fait
des négociations climatiques il y a une
très grande disparité d'accès aux usages
essentiels qui sont l'énergie qui sont
l'alimentation qui sont l'eau donc quand
on demande à des pays dont la population
en majorité n'est pas encore à ce niveau
d'accès de faire des efforts par rapport
à leur mode de vie pour impacter les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre c'est
très très mal reçue donc d'où la
difficulté de vin d'où la nécessité
plutôt de bien comprendre que ce
problème est un problème très régional
et très local et que le solutions qui
peuvent être pertinentes pour les ans ne
le seront pas pour les autres
alors plus largement le potentiel pour
revenir sur l'ensemble des secteurs
qu'on a parcouru le potentiel donc on a
évalué alors ici vous retrouver
l'énergie
lusage des sols les bâtiments et les
villes et puis le transport
peut être plus ou moins difficile à
mettre en place en termes de coûts et
donc ce qu'on a
voulu quantifier c'est le niveau de
coûts pour l'évitement de ses émissions
de gaz de tonnes équivalent co2 et on a
identifié vous voyez ce sont les traits
les plus longs que le potentiel qui
permet en fait d'être en dessous de
coups alors le 100 dollars la tonne
c'est ici à peu près dans le rose qu'on
l'a atteint donc ici c'est pas cher ici
c'est de plus en plus cher donc ce sont
bien ces technologies renouvelables dont
j'ai parlé au départ ça va être des
options sur
l'usagé des sols est en fait
la séquestration du carbone notamment
par rapport à l'agriculture
je vais conclure oui donc j'ai une j'ai
encore nous je parle doucement en fait
je ça m'énerve
j'entends parce que j'ai beaucoup de
choses à vous dire donc voilà donc donc
ça c'est les potentiels ça veut dire des
potentiels y en a et y en a dans tous
les secteurs et après la la la
difficulté c'est de mettre en place un
financement et on a évalué que on est
dans un déficit de 3 à 6 fois ce qu'il
faudrait pour financer l'avènement de
toutes ces solutions
malgré le fait que les finances soient
disponibles donc il existe des flux non
des flux financiers potentiels et donc
bon bah ça c'était juste une slide de
conclusions pour rappeler que donc le
les faits sont clairs c'est le moment
maintenant il faut agir et pourrait
insister en conclusion sur le fait qu'
il faut agir mais il ne faut
certainement pas piquer une des
solutions que je viens d'égrainer en eux
la réfléchissant pas dans le système
global que nous devons décarbonés
puisque tout un effet donc de je veux
dire de compensation et de substitution
et que parfois les solutions des uns
peuvent devenir les problèmes des autres
donc ça c'est vraiment la recommandation
est que les débats sectorielles et les
débats clivants sont en général
destructeur est délétère et ne
permettent pas de réfléchir à la
globalité du sujet sur lequel nous
devons tous nous mettre à travailler et
je pense se joue autant que nous dès
aujourd'hui
voilà merci merci c'est pas la
conclusion mais c'est effectivement un
appel
effectivement j'ai bien noté ce que nous
avait dit mais c'est vrai que sur un
certain nombre de sujets nous l'avions
nous mêmes ici à la commission
d'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable quand on a porté
la loi que l'émail résilience pris un
certain nombre d'engagements qui n'ont
pas été retenus notamment je pense au
logement où on avait proposé la baisse
de la tva parce que c'est aussi
important effectivement de si on demande
un certain nombre d'efforts à nos
concitoyens c'est aussi important qu'on
puisse qu'on puisse les accompagner et
je crois que c'était vraiment cette
volonté
qu'on avait / / / par exemple
l'utilisation aux matières des
transports fit tabarot a proposé aussi
la une baisse de tva qui me paraissait
aussi importante parce que si on veut
substituer
des transports qui sont propres à
d'autres transports il faut aussi que
les gens puissent accéder c'est
transport et c'est effectivement quelque
chose qui de et j'ai bien noté que cette
fois ci il faut agir mais pour agir mais
il faut qu'on s'en donne les moyens
voilà mais j'ai un certain nombre de
demandes de parole alors oui alors je
vais donner la parole à pascal martin et
puis après en visio agents
bah si et puis donc jacques fernique
merci président mesdames messieurs mes
chers collègues tout d'abord monsieur le
président merci d'avoir d'organiser
cette audition à destination de
l'ensemble des sénateurs audition qui
nous concerne tous face à l'urgence
extrême de la situation que vous venez
d'écrire à l'instant mesdames et
messieurs vous féliciter pour la qualité
de votre présentation qui est par
définition en un temps très court
synthétique
globale
pédagogique et surtout sans aucune
concession nous permettant d'appréhender
en toute connaissance de cause ces
urgences mondiales
je voulais revenir très brièvement sur
une thématique que monsieur le coz
années a évoqué succinctement dans son
propos notre commission en lien avec la
commission des affaires économique mène
actuellement des travaux sur l'extension
et l'intensification du risque incendie
dans le contexte du réchauffement
climatique à l'origine nous avions
retenu dans le périmètre de nos travaux
la notion de méga feux il nous est
apparu au fil de nos auditions que cette
notion n'était pas très robuste
scientifiquement et juridiquement et
qu'elles ne correspondaient pas à une
réalité tangible sur le territoire
national bien que le risque de voir des
feux extrême et difficilement
contrôlables se développer en france
devrait malheureusement s'accroître dans
les années et décennies à venir en
prenant un peu de hauteur si vous me
permettez l'expression dans quelle
mesure la problématique des incendies et
plus particulièrement celle des feux
extrême dont certains dépassent plus de
cent mille hectares brûlés
aux conséquences notamment
environnementales désastreuses
là aussi cela la liste n'est pas
exhaustive
atteinte grave à la bio diversité
pollution de l'eau pollution de l'air
émission considérables de gaz à effet de
serre donc dans quelle mesure cette
probable problématique des feux extrême
est elle intégrée
dans vos réflexions du groupe 2 du giec
relative à l'adaptation
deuxième question en matière de risque
incendie identifiez vous des bonnes
pratiques d'adaptation et enfin comment
éviter selon vous l'écueil de la malle
adaptation je vous remercie
merci votre question donc alors première
chose que dit le rapport du giec sur la
question des feux de forêt donc
effectivement c'est pas un risque clé
qui est indiqué dans le rapport europe
en revanche c'est un des risques clés
dans le rapport méditerranée est ce que
dit le rapport c'est qu'effectivement en
méditerranée donc le bassin
méditerranéen nord sud en fait les c'est
surtout la partie nord et l'ouest de le
maghreb en fait qui sont concernés parce
qu'il n'y a pas suffisamment de forêt
dans l'est de la méditerranée pourquoi y
ait beaucoup de incendies de forêt eh
bien on voit en fait qu'aujourd'hui la
gestion des forêts s'est améliorée et
que ça s'est traduit par une baisse de
du nombre d' incendies de forêt donc ça
c'est un succès de l'adaptation
pourtant on a eu une augmentation des
périodes qui sont propices aux feux de
forêt donc ça montre en fait
effectivement l'adaptation dans ce cas
là a été un succès malgré tout
l'indication c'est que cette situation
va se renverser c'est à dire qu'avec
l'augmentation des températures
l'extension des périodes qui sont
favorables extraordinaire aurait on va
avoir effectivement à un moment on va
dans les limites de l'adaptation alors
il est des degrés de température exacte
à partir desquels on l'est on les
atteint bon voilà c'est plutôt en fin
voilà je peux pas il faudra regarder
exactement le rapport mais c'est au delà
d'un degré 5 et donc on aura à nouveau
une augmentation de 2 ces incendies de
forêt à ce moment là
alors quelles sont les mesures
d'adaptation qui sont fournis dedans
alors là pour être tout à fait honnête
je suis hors de mon sujet je ne vais pas
vous quittez pas de vous répondre tout
de suite et voilà je préfère vous ne pas
répondre à cette question je suis désolé
oui
oui donc
l'information sur l'aléa c'est à dire
les conditions météorologiques propices
aux incendies vous la trouverez en
particulier à l'interface entre les
rapports des groupes 1 et 2 le rapport
du groupe 2 souligne l'interaction avec
également les pratiques de gestion des
forêts dans beaucoup de régions il
souligne l'importance de s'appuyer sur
les connaissances locales et autochtones
en particulier pour les peuples
autochtones et leur connaissance fine
qui permettent parfois d'arriver à bien
gérer le risque incendie à l'exemple
pour l'australie en particulier qui a
été donné y compris parfois par des
départs de feu volontaires régulier qui
permettent d'éviter l'accumulation de
broussailles qui conduisent même parfois
à des méga-feux le rapport souligne
aussi la difficulté de prendre en compte
dans les outils de modélisation du
climat les processus biologiques je vais
essayer de le décrire dans la partie
physique du climat on considère que les
puits de carbone océanique ou terrestres
perdent leur efficacité au delà de deux
degrés c'est à dire que une fraction
plus faible des émissions annuelles
serait reprise par l'océan et la
végétation du côté de la végétation les
processus biologiques de mortalité
d'arbres de dépérissement de forêt de
dégradation des écosystèmes pris en
compte par le rapport du groupe 2
souligne que cette baisse d'efficacité
sur le stockage de carbone pourrait
apparaître sur les écosystèmes
terrestres entre 1 degré et demi et 2
degrés y compris par rapport à l'effet
des incendies de forêt
merci un visio je vais donner la parole
à jean masson
merci monsieur le président mais vas-y
merci monsieur le président et mesdames
et messieurs merci pour voir
vous faites vos rapports et pose
informations si vous permettez je vais 2
de fake de questions à vous poser
notre commission courait
sur la problématique est l'adaptation
dans notre pays c'est de sauver et aux
régions dans le cadre du nationalisme
réchauffement climatique
dans ce cadre la commission vont
notamment
l'occasion de se déplacer
excusez moi mais j'ai un écoute ou qui
est monstrueux
j'espère que ça va aller un petit peu
mieux non c'est toujours pareil je suis
désolé que publie
donc je disais notre mission va se
déplacer dans le var
où est publié puis l'excusé
malheureusement
annonciateur l'équipe d' incendies qui
ont facilité le réchauffement
climatique
d'expérience ou de quoi rendre nous
apprend qu'une meilleure coordination
entre les règles dessus du droit de
l'environnement
ayant pour vocation de protéger la
biodiversité
et du pain de forestier pourrait
faciliter la prévention des saisons
une application plus pratique du code de
l'environnement aurait par exemple
permis la démo c'est le
débroussaillement indispensable à la
limitation de la propagation
feu dans la réserve naturelle nationale
de la peine de mort
dans ce cas on boit qu'une adaptation au
réchauffement que même un peu parfois
contradictoires entre nos objectifs de
préservation de la biodiversité
aussi indispensable au maintien des
conditions d'habitabilité de notre
planète comment abordez vous cette
question de la potentielle comme
ritualité en train d' adaptation aurait
chaque au réchauffement climatique d'une
part et le respect de nos autres
objectifs de politique environnementale
d'autres passent
merci fait que j'ai une question
aujourd'hui admet sud nous nous explique
qu'un hectare de forêt mairie
méditerranéen et qui brûlent roulage
46 tonnes d'équivalent co2
d'autres réflexions
sans nous montrer que la production d'un
hectare de forêt en production stocks en
queue de tonnes d'équivalent co2
si on regarde à l'horizon 2030 puisque
c'est l'objectif le premier objectif sur
les dix premières années l'état
reconnaît ne retiendra pas grand-chose
sur 10 am ça nous amène à 304 tonnes de
co2 qui ont été lâchés ou n'ont capté
par un hectare de forêt tirer sur les
brunes et
en 2021 ces deux femmes un teigneux
l'état qui ont mené autour de la
méditerranée
d'impact sur 10 ha
nous donne entre 75 et 80 millions de
tomes d'impact cm2
le pack 55 alloués à la forêt le renault
de cap et 310 millions de tonnes de co2
donc on s'aperçoit que quatre étaient
comme 2021
mais cette précision à ses romans
partagez vous ces chiffres sinon vous
trouver des informations correctes
que préconisez-vous pour réduire ces
incidences et sa charge que
75% des feux de forêt sont d'origine
humaine
merci monsieur le rapporteur je vais
donner la parole à monsieur le cozannet
et puis après on prendra part quatre
questions parce qu'on est si vous
pouviez
maintenir à 2 minutes ce serait bien
qu'on puisse effectivement poser toutes
les questions et avoir toutes les
réponses
alors première chose je veux dire que le
rapport du giec son mandat c'est
d'examiner en fait les conséquences du
changement climatique et l'adaptation à
l'échelle de grandes régions et donc
notamment ya rien de spécifique en fait
à la méditerranée enfin deux régions
méditerranéennes françaises quand on
regarde la méditerranée c'est
effectivement en fait l'ensemble du
bassin méditerranéen
l'espagne l'italie la france étant le de
la résolution maximale en fait sur
laquelle on regarde la deuxième chose
c'est vous avez cité des mesures
d'adaptation et vous avez cité des
difficultés que vous aviez avec ses
mesures d'adaptation et je crois que le
rapport dit enfin je suis même sûr que
le rapport dit très clairement que
là ces questions en fait de feux de
forêt pour limiter leur impact la
première chose à faire c'est limité des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
stabiliser le climat entre 1 degré 5 et
2 degrés voilà sûr
sûr sûr
sûr les questions en fait des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre qui sont liées à
ces incendies de forêt je pense que
c'est assez clair en fait que dans le
monde actuel avec les émissions du
secteur des transports du secteur de
l'énergie etc la question du stockage ou
des émissions de co2 par les forêts en
fête c'est lors des incendies c'est
assez mineur en fait c'est à dire on va
se poser la question du stockage de co2
par les forêts au moment où on aura déjà
considérablement limité des émissions et
là on aura quelque chose il ya quelque
chose à faire sur l'agroécologie donc
effectivement les questions agricoles et
favoriser les pratiques agricoles qui
favorisent l écosystème favorise le
stockage de co2 voilà mais je pense en
fait que les inquiétudes par rapport aux
émissions de gaz à effet de serre lors
d'un incendie de forêt aujourd'hui on
est vraiment un ou deux degrés de
d'ordre de grandeur en dessous du
problème des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre liées aux autres sources
oui je vous en prie
donc ceux qui
évoluent actuellement est
très important dans ces situations de
anticipation justement des forêts
possible des forêts possibles sont des
services climatiques qui peuvent
effectivement prévoir une augmentation
excessive de la température qui se
développe beaucoup dans les services
climatiques aussi on intègre
actuellement les peuples autochtones et
les gens qui les spécialistes aussi de
feux peuvent
donner des conseils dont il a co
construction de savoir et aussi les
early warning system
qui est un outil très important dans la
gestion de risque et qui peut
éventuellement prévenir les gens de
l'arrivée des forêts et anticiper
la possibilité à temps voilà
je te rajoute un dernier point la
question en fait de l'évolution du puits
de carbone forestier elle est
explicitement abordés dans le rapport du
haut conseil pour le climat qui est
rendue publique aujourd'hui donc c'est
un puits de carbone forestier qui a
atteint un maximum dans les années 2010
et qui a diminué en particulier d'une
augmentation par une augmentation de la
mortalité d'arbres et une diminution de
la croissance est juste de mon point de
vue la question de la gestion des feux
de forêt elle demande d'être intégré
dans une réflexion plus large sur une
gestion durable des forêts face aux
multiples attentes c'est-à-dire le bois
énergie le bois matériau la biodiversité
la diversité forestière qui permettra
d'avoir des forêts plus résiliente dans
un climat avec plus de stress thermique
et hydrique et le stockage de carbone
sur pied ou dans les sols forestiers et
il ya une vraie difficulté qui est
soulignée donc là c'est pas le gie acm
et le haut conseil pour le climat le
souligne d'avoir en fait une stratégie
d'ensemble sur une gestion soutenable
des forêts et sachant que pour donner un
ordre de grandeur à un france ça ne
contrebalance entre guillemets le puits
de carbone forestier que 4% de
l'ensemble des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre
eric gold
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président merci
mesdames et monsieur pour cette
présentation des risques extrêmes et des
leviers d'action possible moi ma
question portera sur l'énergie
vous êtes quelques uns à avoir pris
position ou entre le cas vous être
exprimé sur le traité sur la charte de
l'énergie qui semble incohérent avec
l'ambition de limiter le réchauffement
climatique un degré 5 et 1 courir ont
aussi avec la nécessaire fermeture de
certaines infrastructures d'énergies
fossiles même si des efforts ont
semble-t-il été réalisés pour améliorer
ce traité l'absence d'unanimité au
niveau européen pose problème et ne
permet pas d'avancées significatives
des aménagements de la charte devrait
entrer en vigueur dès septembre moi
j'aimerais tout simplement avoir votre
regard d'expert sur serre des astuces et
dernières décisions
merci je vais pendant encore trois
collectes pour la question et puis vous
répondre après je vais donner la parole
à martin décidera qu
est ce que tout le monde l'entend oui
oui oui bonjour bonjour merci président
moi je vais vous poser une question
concernant les travaux du groupe 3 qui a
travaillé sur l'atténuation madame asie
a évoqué effectivement un certain nombre
d éléments qui a occupé ce groupe de
travail et autres ces mesures
d'atténuation j'aurais souhaité
également évoqué le stockage de carbone
particulièrement dans les villes madama
sont des mots devient de de l'évoquer à
travers les
forêts mais dans les modèles l'apport
des députés carbone les masses et il me
semble qu'il serait utile notamment pour
les derniers kilomètres à parcourir vers
la neutralité carbone et on sait que
c'est un sujet qui est très prégnant
dans nos villes aujourd'hui la loi
climat résilience d'ailleurs avait
abordé
avait effleuré également cette
thématique
cependant les puits de carbone comme nos
forêts nos océans subissent des
altérations qui réduisent leurs
capacités
séquestré ce carbone on vient de
l'évoquer à travers la question qui
vient d'être posée par un collègue
précédemment donc mais kg de questions
qui sont très simples qu'il peut être
l'impact réel de ces puits de carbone à
l'horizon 2030 et 2050 et les modèles
prend-il en considération des puits de
carbone afin d'évaluer leur importance
dans l'atteinte de nos objectifs
vous avez bien compris les pubs carbone
que j'évoque c'est essentiellement ce
que l'on pourrait avoir dans nos villes
au coeur de nos villes merci merci chers
collègues je les donne la parole à
monsieur gilles et
voilà je suis parent excusez moi
monsieur le président merci vous abordez
dans le chapitre iv l'impact sur le
changement climatique concernant les
ccls hydrologiques vous avez juste un
peu abordée effectivement ce sujet
peut-être qu'on pourrait aller un peu de
douleur mais si on en fait un résumé
rapide c'est bien sur
l'approfondissement des cycles de
sécheresse des précipitations intenses
et donc des phénomènes d'ailleurs
globalement de plus en plus intense et
vous préciser que 44% des catastrophes
climatiques depuis les années 70 sont
liées à des situations d'inondations
donc on a là des événements qui sont
effectivement majeur ce qui pose la
question de la prise en charge des
risques assurantiels et d'ailleurs vous
évoquer la question des solidarités des
solidarités humaines et c'est un sujet
qui est majeur aujourd'hui et
pourrait-on on pourrait peut-être
effectivement y revenir j'ai apprécié le
fait qu'aujourd'hui
vous avancez aussi un certain nombre de
scénarios en termes de propositions
d'action et ce sont des éléments peut
être un peu différent que ce que l'on a
pu entendre jusqu'à maintenant et ses
scénarios en termes de propositions
d'actions pour tout vous dire en tant
que politique on souhaiterait d'ailleurs
qu'ils aillent au delà pour aller sur
des scénarios en termes de modélisation
économique parce qu'en fait aujourd'hui
la capacité à faire se poser vous l'avez
abordé à un moment donné la politique
des moyens en fonction des besoins et on
voit bien que nous dans les paradoxes
que l'on peut avoir c'est à dire entre
les intentions et l'action on à cette
problématique là d'avoir une vision
cohérente sur des scénarios et des
modèles économiques qui nous permettrait
de faire et ses scénarios la russie a
une capacité démonstrative voire
peut-être
provocante à certains moments mais une
capacité démonstrative de dire qu'il y a
des champs du possible et qu'on peut y
arriver mais aujourd'hui on manque
effectivement de cette matière et les
enjeux au niveau de l'eau d'ailleurs le
démontre assez bien aujourd'hui quand on
regarde également les conflits d'usagé
et les conflits d'usagé à caractère
immédiat et j'en terminerai la
l'événementiel nous ramène
malheureusement parfois sur des réflexes
assez malheureux la crise de la guerre
en ukraine
nous amène aujourd'hui dans des choix
énergétiques qui sont complètement
paradoxaux par rapport à nos objectifs
que l'on doit atteindre tout simplement
parce que en termes de modèles
économiques et des usages on est
aujourd'hui malgré tout à des réflexes
immédiat et non pas sur le long terme
merci madame préville
six présidents et merci mesdames et
monsieur de vos présentations très
enrichissante moi j'avais d'abord une
première question sur le message votre
message que vous avez que vous
fournissez à toute la société comment le
vivez-vous est-ce que vous avez évoqué
le ce problème des journalistes qui
n'auraient peut-être pas bien compris ce
que vous aviez voulu exprimer et puis je
vais croiser ça avec ce que vient de
d'évoquer mon collègue sur ce qui se
passe parce que ce que l'état des lieux
que vous faites se croisent avec la
réalité que nous sommes en train de
vivre et notamment cette guerre en
ukraine qui dont la déflagration n'a pas
encore donné toutes ses chroniques ce
coût de ses conséquences en cascade et
qui forcément vont impacter tous qu'on
est en train de mettre en place alors
comment fait-on pour intégrer ça pour
parce que finalement ce qui arrive là
c'est tout simplement l'histoire humaine
que cela a toujours été comme ça et que
finalement
les rapports évidemment son sont
évidemment essentiel mais quelque part
comment tenir compte du fait que dans
l'histoire de l'humanité il ya toujours
l'émergence dessus de dalea alors qu'une
guerre ce pas un alias pire que çà mais
de d'événements comme ceux là qui
bouscule tous et qui remettent en
question tout ce qu'on a essayé de
mettre en place alors comment fait-on
pour pour envisager cela et puis j'ai
une autre question puisque j'étais juste
avant de venir là dans le comité de
bassin adour-garonne et que j'ai entendu
l'état 2 du hydrographique du bassin
avait beaucoup d'inquiétudes
sur les sécheresses sur le déficit de
précipitations moins 20% quand même ces
derniers temps et puis quelque chose qui
maintenant s'inscrit dans de manière
durable
comment fait-on pour
intégrer le fait que finalement quelque
part cela va plus vite qu'on ne le
prévoyait donc voilà mais ici on merci
merci avant de vous donner à propos
répond je veux donner la parole un autre
collègue jacques fernique oui merci
effectivement merci de vous prêter à
cette audition d'autant plus bienvenus
ma collègue prévient différentes visions
qu' il ya eu un
fâcheux contresens
déclenché vous l'avez dit par la fpc
fameux trois ans pour agir que le grand
public a traduit en de toute façon c'est
fichu rien ne sera entrepris après ce
sera trop tard mais je crois que c'est
aussi significatif d'une certaine
paresse intellectuelle
de nos médias mais aussi on peut se
regarder nous-mêmes des décideurs
politiques à l'égard des successifs
communication du giec en gros moi j'ai
le sentiment quand on sait qu'elles vont
tomber qu'elles vont arriver on se dit
que toute manière on sait ce qu'elle
regarde dedans et est donc on y regarde
pas de plus près et on se contente de
quelques formules simplificatrice et
s'est aussi dit cathy d'ailleurs que je
parlais paresse intellectuelle décideurs
si on se rappelle les débats lors des
rendez-vous les quelques rendez-vous de
débats de cette période électorale quand
les journalistes disaient allez on
aborde le climat ça signifiait qu'on
allait causer quelques instants vous
étiez amusant tout à l'heure du de notre
différents favoris sur nucléaire versus
renouvelables et on en restait là bon
donc déjà comment réussir à bousculer
cette paresse pour faire comprendre
qu'il ya des éléments intéressants
discutable de vrais sujets de vrais
enjeux et que c'est pas simplement des
des lapalissades que que vous déployez
l'autre partie de la question pour pas
être trop long les politiques
d'atténuation de baisse des émissions
pour beaucoup vous avez évoqué le
caractère tendu difficile des
discussions même en votre sein et pour
le grand public on le voit très bien il
le traduisent en ça sera l'austérité ça
sera l'arrêt précisément des capacités
en gros on va vivre moins bien donc en
quoi réussir à rendre crédible l'idée
que de traiter deux paires l'action
climatique et la réduction des
inégalités
ça peut ouvrir des perspectives moins
sombres plus désirable merci pour
permettre une réponse globale qui est
peut-être finir les questions comme ça
ce sera fait je répondais globalement
alors monsieur bruno belin
merci président pi ca sion enchaîne très
bien avec l'intervention de notre
président collègues
comment faire en sorte que ce rapport et
merci monsieur merci mesdames de nous
avoir présenté
vous êtes devant des gens convaincus
comment on fait en sorte que le grand
public se l'approprient
avec paul faury ça serait quand même un
peu exagéré mais avec une envie partagée
là quand vous écoute on sort le prozac 1
et c'est parce qu'on a envie d'entendre
en tout cas pour 99% de la population
aujourd'hui comment on arrive à faire en
sorte que le sujet soit moins clip bien
qu libre vous prenez des exemples très
fort au niveau international à les
nourrir un milliard en afrique d'êtres
humains aujourd'hui avec les éléments
que vous donnez vous n'y arrivez pas on
n'y arrive pas à les loger aussi ça le
sujet de l'habitat est essentiel dans un
une planète de 2 10 milliards
d'habitants en 2050 on n'y arrive pas
aujourd'hui mais quand je dis que c'est
clivant et évidemment discriminatoire
vous avez pris un exemple qu'on connaît
tous ici moi je suis la tête département
vin un secteur où il ya vingt habitants
kilomètres carrés y'a pas de tram on
sait pas ce que c'est que fall dernier
tracé 1954 ma grand mère m'en a parlé
mais on ne voit plus
comment on fait pour effectivement
circulé la voiture voilà ce sont des
vrais sujets climent l'avion c'est pas
bon bah ouais sauf que l'avion
électrique ça n'existe pas encore
aujourd'hui on ennuie hier une
démonstration dans le groupe d'étude
aviation civile
l'hydrogène pour l'avion c'est pas
possible aujourd'hui avec de base dans
le monde court ou équipe canada les
l'hydrogène c'est aussi d'électricité et
donc aussi comment on apporte des
réponses sur la question de
l'électricité aujourd'hui qui est
essentiel voilà en fait ces sujets là
sont clivant sur le territoire chez nous
les habitants ses fourches d'un côté dès
qu'on parle d'éoliennes enfin on n'est
que sur des sujets où on s'oppose et on
se divise alors que c'est un sujet
essentiel pour nous tous donc comment
faire en sorte et j'arrive à mes deux
minutes que ce sujet soit partagé merci
président
de tissot
merci monsieur le président à mon tour
de vous remercier pour la présentation
pour les présentations vous nous avez
fait et c'est vrai que notre collègue
vient de dire ici que des convaincus
donc on a soit lu quelques morceaux des
rapports soient soit écouté certains de
vos propos moi j'ai bien compris la
réflexion doit être globale et j'en suis
intimement convaincu mais je vais quand
même aborder un sujet particulier c'est
l'agriculture et l'important ce cas là
en tant que secteur émetteur de gaz à
effet de serre mais aussi la question
qu'on doit se poser aujourd'hui c'est
comment les agriculteurs les éleveurs
d'aujourd'hui et de demain ont cette
responsabilité d'agir et pour ne pas
être
pour ne pas être que des acteurs du
dérèglement climatique et surtout ne
plus être les principales victimes
aussi de manière assez transversale
parce que et
de manière à pouvoir soulever la
temporalité parce que vous l'avez dit à
différentes reprises je pense que c'est
important aujourd'hui d'inscrire
dans des délais très courts des
démarches à engager et
pour cette cette problématique vous nous
avez dit à différentes reprises vous
l'avez dit aussi tout à l'heure on va
devoir se tourner vers de nouvelles
technologies et je voudrais avoir une
précision à ce sujet là qu'est ce que
vous entendez derrière nouvelles
technologies c'est des nouvelles
technologies
génétiques mécanique informatique donc
voilà c'est une question assez précise
et
quels sont pour vous ou qu'elle pourrait
être pour vous et c'est vrai on l'a dit
à différentes reprises c'est que le
modèle agricole qu'on connaît quasiment
partout en europe en france en
particulier c'est un modèle assez
intensif et on connaît la raison pour
laquelle ce modèle a encore mis en avant
et moi je compte on devrait compter sur
vos propositions parce que vous êtes
enfin vos avis sont indiscutables on
peut ne pas vouloir les écouter on peut
ne pas vouloir les entendre mais vous
faites que c'est qu'un état de fait et
et les scénarios vous proposés sont
indiscutables à mon sens donc est ce qu
on pourrait avoir un dd des scénarios un
scénario puisque vous pourriez imaginer
un scénario à l'échelle de notre pays
finalement ou peut-être européen mais de
notre pays et si vous arriviez à
démontrer que ces scénarios sont
positifs aussant ce
climat on va dire ça nous aiderait nous
législateurs
aaa imposé en guillemets des systèmes
qui pourraient être
bénéfices tant pour le monde agricole
les gens qui en vivent et puis pour la
planète
merci je vais donner la parole à
monsieur seulement depuis didier novelli
et stéphane demilly
merci monsieur le président merci pour
votre présentation cet immense travail
que constitue les rapports du giec alors
je vous dis bravo aussi de ne pas
sombrer dans le désespoir ou la colère
puisque ces rapports s'empilent année
après année et si peu de choses avancent
et la lucidité nous inviterait plutôt de
au désespoir puisque françois je men qui
est à travailler avec vous parle de
suicide collectif pour l'humanité vu la
pente sur laquelle on est
donc effectivement il ne faut pas aller
assez à ces émotions là il faut
s'engager vraiment dans une transition
mais comment faire pour sortir de ces
injonctions contradictoires sur lequel
sont fondées les bases de notre économie
aujourd'hui c'est à dire on incite tout
un chacun à consommer toujours plus en
permanence quel est le rôle de la
publicité et en même temps et bien
effectivement il ya quelques messages
subliminaux sur le fait de dire il faut
aller vers de la sobriété de la
frugalité alors comment mettre notre
économie au service de cette sobriété de
cette frugalité je pense que c'est un
grand défi puisque depuis des décennies
elle s'est construite sur une croissance
perpétuelle et donc voilà si on ne
trouve pas vraiment les éléments pour
aller vers ce changement de paradigme je
pense qu'on va buter et puis
effectivement comment faire pour que les
médias et que à certains noms de
personnes ne s'empare pas de de toutes
les propositions toujours avec le mot
derrière de punitif des comptes dès
qu'on parle de consommation de viande
punitif on parle de mobilité en avion
c'est punitif enfin ou un moment qui est
ce qu'il va être puni réellement donc je
pense que on a tout un chacun aussi à
faire d une
je vais dire
de fortes
je ne trouve pas le terme adéquat mais à
un remettre en cause nos propos au
quotidien merci merci la parole est un
délit merci monsieur le président mon
jeu
je vais essayer d'être un peu plus
mesuré ce que je ne cèderai pas au
catastrophisme et au désespoir et c'est
le sens d'ailleurs de mon intervention
moi qui suis engagée depuis toujours sur
ces questions est depuis 20 ans en tant
qu'élu j'ai pu mesurer à la fois
le fait que tous ceux qui alerté depuis
longtemps et je pense notamment premier
candidat écologiste élections
présidentielles en 1974 rené dumont qui
déjà alerté sur la question de la
ressource et et ces sujets
on peut mesurer le chemin parcouru à la
fois parce que ya aujourd'hui plus de
climato sceptiques je pense fera
j'espère et la prise de conscience et
les réels et les actions elles sont
engagée fortement et c'est ce qui
ressort également de votre rapport il ya
des beaucoup de prise de conscience il
ya beaucoup de questions d'adaptation
vous préconisez vous proposer des
solutions donc moi je considère
aujourd'hui que
les données sont intégrées par j'espère
le plus grand nombre moi si je regarde
les programmes notamment de télé
publique fin des chaînes publiques en
tout cas depuis quelques semaines et
quelques mois la semaine dernière il ya
un magnifique une magnifique émission
sur france 3 avec jamy gourmaud ce n'est
pas le fait que ce soit un vendéen mais
c'est de la pédagogie ce la
vulgarisation
et ça a été suivie par plus de 2
millions de spectre de téléspectateurs
sur l'érosion du trait de côte et les
submersions marines l'avenir du littoral
je crois que aujourd'hui à des émissions
grand public qui relève au message en
réalité parce que c'est vrai que c'est
pas en montrant des graphiques au grand
public et sert à longueur de journée en
les alertant sur les sur les
conséquences dramatiques puisque les
médias ne retiennent que ça
malheureusement qu'on va réussir à faire
changer les comportements
moi je voulais sur la question de la
démographie vous avez évoqué les 10
milliards d'habitants et horizon 2050
j'ai longtemps je suis longtemps
intervenu sur ces sujets là parce que
c'est vrai que la question de la
ressource elle est liée aussi à cette
démographie galopante dans un certain
nombre d'endroits du globe mais il faut
aussi comprendre que un petit américain
consommera un peu plus qu'un petit
nigérian et que son impact qu'une
famille 10 en afrique n'a pas le même
impact qu une famille de 10 enfants aux
etats unis je parle même pas de la
france qui est un niveau en dessous donc
donc c'est vrai qu'ils font pour
pondérer un peu tout ça moi ce que je
voudrais c'est qu'on est quand même un
message d'espoir pour notre jeunesse
parce que et notamment je pense aux
18-35 ans
on avait d'ailleurs comment ils
n'allaient pas voter un pour 70% d'entre
eux aux dernières échéances mais
peut-être parce qu'on leur on leur
laisse pas beaucoup de da venir autre
perspective et qu'il considère que c'est
trop tard et que rien n'a été fait rien
n'est fait par les politiques en tout
cas
malgré tout les alertes que vous pouvez
lancer et donc moi ce que je voudrais
c'est qu'on puisse alors c'est vrai que
c'est une ligne de crête il faut
continuer à interpeller il faut
continuer à sensibiliser il faut
continuer à marteler le message parce
qu'il faut que cette prise de conscience
perdure mais mais dans le même temps il
faut aussi qu'on donne des motifs
d'espérance d'espoir à nos jeunes en
lisant que c'est possible on va y
arriver tous ensemble et moi je vous
invite je pense que vous l'avez lu à
parcours est un ouvrage que j'avais cité
d'ailleurs déjà la commission et que ça
s'appelle les émotions du dérèglement
climatique par un psychiatre et un
docteur antoine pelissolo et céline
masini l'impact des catastrophes
écologiques sur notre bien-être et
comment y faire face et je vous invite à
lire parce que je pense que votre regard
enfin je pense je me tourne vers mes
collègues pour échanger et et nous
devons et c'est pour ça que je prend le
contre-pied parce que il faut pas que
nous on est un message de désespoir
vis-à-vis de notre jeunesse alors nous
on peut se le dire entre nous que c'est
compliqué que c'est difficile qui a
beaucoup de choses à faire encore qu'il
faut que nos dirigeants que ce soit en
france ou ailleurs s'engage sur ces
questions là mais je pense qu'il faut
trouver le message pas forcément le rôle
du gie acm est trouvé le message c'est
aussi notre responsabilité de d un
message d'espoir tout simplement parce
que quand on interroge les jeunes
français aujourd'hui et puis d'autres en
europe ils nous disent quoi je veux pas
avoir d'enfant parce que je voudrais a
impacté la planète et c'est terrible
comme message qu'est-ce qu'on leur
laisse moi même pas cette perspective de
pouvoir un jour être parent enfin et
c'est je trouve ça terrible donc c'est
un peu un message cri de coeur mais mais
mais je pense qu'on a une responsabilité
individuelle et collective
des choses s'accélèrent malheureusement
dans le mauvais sens pour le climat mais
il n'est pas trop tard et on peut tous
ensemble y arriver en continuant à
marteler les messages en agissant
surtout
merci pour ce message d'espoir stéphane
demilly merci président je termine cette
salve de questions
par moi aussi un remerciement quant à la
la clarté de vos propos et
quant à la clarté du constat permettait
juste une petite remarque amicale de
forme d'un parlementaire qui siège à la
francophonie depuis 20 ans quand des
experts français viennent devant un
parlement français ce serait bien que
les slides soit en français ça
faciliterait ça faciliterait la
compréhension et on vous remercie de
votre prochaine délicatesse sur le sujet
entre le moment où j'ai sollicité le
président proposait une question et
maintenant j'ai eu là la précision que
j'attendais alors je vais vous poser une
question très très général
parmi toutes les priorités que vous avez
évoquées quelle est la priorité des
priorités pour le dire de façon
tautologique si vous étiez parlementaire
dans cette commission si vous aviez le
moindre pouvoir exécutif gouvernementale
sur quel d'accélérateur
appuyez-vous prioritairement
merci bien
mesdames messieurs je vous laisse le
soin de d'organiser la façon dont vous
allez répondre et de reprendre des
questions de mes collègues merci
je vais répondre à ce dont je me
souviens mais à chaque fois que
le
déjà je pense que ce que vous avez
souligné c'est ce problème d'échelle
temporel donc du court terme et du très
long terme et nous notre rôle c'est
quelque part de porter le regard plus
loin et d'évaluer vers quoi nous sommes
en train de nous orienter et je pense
que nous avons comme mission avec la
sortie de ces rapports de délivrer les
faits alors en fait moi je vais
témoigner pour moi personnellement ça ne
m'angoisse pas du tout parce que je
pense qu'il ya vraiment une opportunité
de transformation profonde de notre
société de notre modèle qui est un
challenge et qui en plus un très belle
aventure pour toute la jeunesse et c'est
vraiment comme ça que je pense qu'il
faut poser le problème et c'est pour ça
que moi je milite beaucoup en faveur de
des cliver et d' arrêter d'opposer parce
que ça nous mène absolument rien et donc
il faut vraiment rester dans cette cette
idée qu'on peut construire par contre il
va falloir se remettre en question et je
pense que pour se remettre en question
la première chose à faire c'est à être
conscients de la situation or vous dites
que vous êtes tous avertis mais je suis
même pas sûr que les jeunes soient
vraiment très avertis enfin c'est des
bribes
cdc des choses catastrophiques de droite
de gauche mais c'est même pas je m'aime
pas sur moi que ce soit la question
climatique qui angoisse il ya quand même
la guerre il ya comme un vent fort ya
quand même tout un tas de choses autour
de nous qui sont pas forcément très
enthousiasmante donc ça c'est un peu
pour le la réponse ah
qu'est-ce que dans quel état finalement
on est et quel est notre notre
positionnement alors après les
difficultés que je vois c'est
donc les médias sont complètement
délirant de mon point de vue le premier
volet c'était le transfert de messi le
deuxième volet c'était la gare en
ukraine le troisième volet c'était les
élections présidentielles ils ont une
forte responsabilité
mais en même temps je veux dire les
médias c'est pour les vieux je pense que
les jeunes n'ont rien à faire de ce qui
se passe à la télé ou donc donc il ya
beaucoup de vecteurs de communication
aujourd'hui et peut-être qu'on peut ne
pas s'arrêter là moi je pense que notre
notre auditoire alors si vous dites que
tous les politiques sont vraiment
conscients du sujet on était devant
l'assemblée nationale la semaine
dernière tout le monde n'est pas venu
vin comme allemand pour discuter avec
les membres du giec qui étaient là pour
essayer de changer donc je moi je suis
pas du tout optimiste sur le niveau 2 de
prise en compte du sujet par notre monde
politique au delà notre monde politique
nous avons les gouvernants je suis pas
très sûr non plus qu'ils aient bien
compris le problème est ce que leurs
actions ne traduit pas en fait cette
cette mesure alors après je puis je veux
pas accaparer la parole une
attendez je veux juste voir oui alors il
ya eu des petites choses sur c'est quoi
les technologies qui sont les solutions
mais en fait je pense quand même qu'on
est dans un très grand brouillard et je
pense que à cette demande est-ce que
vous avez le scénario positif qui
permettrait de résoudre le problème et
comme ça on serait plus convaincus on
pourrait y aller une fois il faut
arrêter d'attendre ça il faut arrêter
d'attendre ça parce que vous avez vu il
ya des vendeurs de scénario c'est comme
des collections de prêt-à-porter je suis
désolé de le dire mais je le dis à mes
collègues tu as les trucs de les yeux
qui sortent en automne tu as les autres
verte machin qui sortent et finalement
vous en faites quoi vous c'est beaucoup
trop compliqué de travailler comme ça je
pense qu'il faut dire bon ben ok on a un
vrai sujet et puis on identifie que le
modèle dans lequel on s est un vrai
sujet vous avez parlé de publicité nous
dans notre chapitre en fait quand on a
travaillé sur la demande ont sediba
effectivement la vision de qu'est-ce que
c'est mon bien-être est quand même très
associée au fait que toute la journée on
voit défiler des pubs avec une très
belle voiture grosses cylindrées sur une
route déserte en général côtières et
salaire de
nous renvoyer l'image du bonheur mais
c'est ça le problème en fait le fond du
problème il est là il est que les
valeurs et on a beaucoup travaillé
là-dessus les valeurs les normes ne sont
pas alignés avec le sujet dont on parle
et en plus elles n'ont pas l'air de
véhicules et tant de bonheur que ça vu
le nombre de gens qui vont choix cette
psychiatre soissons sous prozac donc il
ya un vrai questionnement de fond donc
donc je pense que ça s'est vraiment mais
je dire en fait une époque assez
formidable parce qu'il va falloir tout
changer un et c'est moi je pense que
c'est le message qu'il faut absolument
porter et à partir de là
désorienté alors vous avez cité rené
dumont mais je veux dire il y en a plein
qui se sont cassé les dents le club de
rome enfin tout ça quelque part on le
savait très bien les scientifiques ont
confirmé avec des preuves tangibles
supplémentaires rapport après rapport
comme l'a dit valérie aujourd'hui les
faits sont clairs la colle à la
concomitance entre nos activités et ses
dérèglements est sûr à 100% donc je veux
dire il faut simplement dire les sujets
alors vous avez parlé de la charte de
l'énergie magique je connais même pas ce
truc donc faire parler de ça mais disons
que l'idée que alors encore une fois les
fausses insa un sujet mais il faut
travailler avec l'industrie fossile faut
pas dire les fossiles ils sont méchants
parce qu'il faut transformer toute cette
industrie en fait il faut transformer
tout le monde et moi je pense que c'est
pour ça que c'est ça le challenge
intéressant c'est que on va pas bannir
du jour au lendemain un nez avec un
secteur par rapport à un autre d'abord
ils sont pas ils sont méchants mais en
fait on n'en dépend tous quand même donc
donc il ya un vrai sujet de fond pour ne
pas se retrouver dans des situations
comme celle qu'on a quand même découvert
à la guerre en ukraine c'est à dire que
nos voisins allemands qui étaient des
donneurs de leçons de l'europe étaient
eux-mêmes dépendants à 70 % du gaz russe
on s'en moque c'est du gaz quand même et
que maintenant ils sont en train de
relancer le charbon je veux dire donc ça
ça veut dire que ce sont les
préparations qui on n'était pas et je
pense que c'est là où il faut se poser
la question 2 est ce que vous voulez
vraiment ou modifiées et auquel cas
c'est pas juste je des taxes tel truc je
relève la tva l'âge la baisse là bas
c'est beaucoup plus profond que ça alors
je vais faire une petite page de pub si
vous me le permettez parce que au-delà
de véhiculer des messages en fait nous
aussi on va agir à notre niveau donc moi
je suis à l'école des mines de paris et
donc ce qu'on a décidé cette créer un
grand institut qui s'appelle de
transition' stich août 1.5 désolé pour
l'anglicisme
et dans lequel ce qu'on veut c'est un
inclure nos jeunes en fait c'est pour
nos jeunes un nouveau parcours
académique un nouveau parcours
doctorales et ce qu'on veut aussi c'est
faire de l' influence vis-à-vis de gens
comme vous c'est à dire que nos travaux
on veut les faire remonter pour que vous
puissiez en bénéficier je pense que tout
le monde est dans un brouillard très
épais et c'est tout à fait
compréhensible et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui à la question qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire eh bien il faut
vraiment essayer de d'éclaircir et pour
prendre des décisions il faut pas se
jeter sur une techno une autre en bannir
une ou une autre il faut vraiment avoir
cette réflexion de fond et mobiliser
tout le monde pour qu'on aille tous dans
le même sens donc voilà c'est çà mau
donc là c'est pas un message du giec
parce que dans ma bouche pas le moins
décevante mais merci
merci pour j'avais expliqué que les
faits sont clairs vos propos aussi c'est
très bien
vous avez effectivement évoqué le fait
que vous ayez assez nationaliser peu
répondu vous avez vu que les sénateurs
eux ont bien répondu à cet échange et
ils savent pas jouer que je ne sais pas
combien il ya de sénateurs ont tous
je vais alors voilà donc il ya eu
beaucoup de questions des questions par
exemple sur les questions de ressources
en eau donc effectivement les ressources
en eau il ya des mesures d'adaptation
qui existent par exemple les collègues
du brgm travail sur la recharge des
fêtes de la recharge artificielle des
nappes souterraines par exemple ce qu'il
faut bien voir s'il ya des limites à
cette adaptation et notamment dans le
sud de l'europe bah en fait on voit déjà
qu'on a des sécheresses de plus en plus
importante avec des impacts sur
l'énergie des barrages qui se
remplissent de manière insuffisante sur
l'agriculture des pros père de
production agricole et puis en fait des
pénuries d'eau qui affecte les habitants
ensuite des questions sur les modèles
économiques donc j'ai vu que vous avez
lu le rapport merci beaucoup mais
effectivement je pense que sur la
question du modèle économique
où on a des limites dans les modèles
économiques on utilise mais bon je pense
pas qu'on puisse dire que le giec
n'utilisait pas de modèle économique
dans le domaine en fait qui m'intéresse
c'est notamment les modèles économiques
pour la question en fait de deux
catastrophes naturelles et par exemple
il ya une alerte en fait dans le rapport
qui est que
une tempête une inondation disons liés
en 2100 avec une élévation niveau de la
mer de 2,1 m en angleterre elle va avoir
des impacts directs ça on peut le
quantifier mais elle va aussi avoir des
impacts indirects donc en fait ce qui va
se passer c'est que le système
assurantiel va indemniser certaines
pertes mais il y aura tellement de
pertes en fait vu la dimension des
événements qu'on aura certainement des
défauts dans ses dents dans ce système
assurantiel et également en fait qui se
répercute dans le système financier ce
qui fait qu'à la fin des coûts
économiques sont cinq fois plus
important que la catastrophe direct
alors ça c'est pas une évidence j'irai
c'est une évidence est en train
d'émerger et quelques études qui
mentionne sa décollecte du cired en
france travaille sur ces sujets là mais
je pense effectivement que les sur les
questions des modèles économiques même
si c'est pas ma spécialité il ya quand
même beaucoup de choses qui sont là
après il ya eu la question de l'équité
donc ça c'est extrêmement important dans
le rapport effectivement il ya le
rapport là
le résumer aux décideurs vont semer
explicitement les questions de justice
climatique donc qu'ils sont finalement
ceux qui vont subir l'écologie punitive
c'est à dire ceux qui vont subir les
impacts du changement climatique à
travers les extrêmes de chaleur et à
travers
les risques pour leur santé c'est les
plus pauvres en fait en premier donc les
plus pauvres à l'intérieur des pays et
au niveau international donc en afrique
en asie du sud est sept états et et la
question en fait de la justice
climatique c'est de compenser en fait
cette injustice qui est que ceux qui ont
peu contribué au changement climatique
en subissant premier les impacts donc
comme ça c'est un sujet vraiment
extrêmement important et je pense que
c'est très important que ça a été
approuvé dans le résumé décideurs
les ensuite
sur la question des technologies je
crois que c'est assez clair en fait que
la technologie s'est déployée
massivement des technologies qui existe
déjà c'est plutôt ça en fait l'enjeu que
d'inventer de nouvelles technologies qui
éventuellement nous permettrait d'aller
plus loin
voilà sur la question en fait de
l'adaptation je pense que là il ya le
l'institut for climate économique qui
est français
qui 1,6 en français en fait nous nous a
sorti un rapport en fait il ya sept
semaines qui nous a beaucoup manqué en
fait dans l'évaluation du giec parce que
nous en fait on a essayé d'évaluer
quelles étaient les déficits en terme
d'adaptation en termes de m
d'investissements dans l'adaptation et
il ya des chiffres en fait qui circulent
sur les pays en voie développement c'est
l'ordre de 100 milliards par an en fait
en 2030 mais il y avait pas beaucoup de
chiffres en fait pour des pays comme to
speak mans la france hélas l'institut de
fort que la met economics nous présente
un plan 2,3 milliards à débloquer dès
2022 dans le projet de loi de finances
2009 à nouveau pour 2023 pour des
mesures d'urgence pour l'adaptation dons
qui permettront finalement de limiter
les impacts pour des extrêmes de chaleur
se préparer à l'élévation du niveau de
la mer les risques d'inondation et c'est
ensuite il ya la question en fait j'irai
notre regard est ce que c'est notre
regard qu'on a présenté aujourd'hui pas
du tout en fait c'est pas du tout mon
regard en fait c'est ce qu'il ya dans le
rapport ensuite le tc donc moi j'ai
signé cette tribune en fait sur le tc
eux pourquoi parce qu'effectivement dans
le rapport du giec le groupe 3i les
marques explicitement que ce traité est
une barrière à la transition énergétique
dans le monde parce qu'en fait il crée
un risque financier très important pour
les pays qui voudraient prendre des
mesures qui seraient hostiles à
l'utilisation et à l'extraction
d'hydrocarbures
ensuite les questions de priorité donc
là je vais pas parler du rapport j'irai
dans le rap enfin si quand même dans le
rapport on voit comme des mesures qui
sont positives c'est à dire on voit des
mesures qui d'adaptation d'atténuation
qui sont favorables à la qualité de vie
et ça je dirais c'est vraiment le
tableau avec tous les plus que j'ai
montré dans la présentation donc bah moi
si j'étais en situation de décision je
mettrai la priorité sur les les les
actions d'adaptation et puis
l'atténuation qui qui finalement ont le
plus d'effet positif voilà alors à titre
personnel je suis engagé dans sur les
questions de vélo et effectivement il me
semble que la typiquement personnes
voudraient revenir en arrière dans les
villes françaises au monde à développer
le vélo quoi alors paris grenoble et
ceara et et 300 m en voiture c'est un
kilogramme de glaciers qui va fondre
donc aujourd'hui on a à 50% de part
modale céline c'est que nous le dit en
fait les trajets de moins en moins de
vingt kilomètres c'est la moitié des
cetc de la moitié sont effectués en
voiture en fait donc un potentiel report
modal qui est extrêmement important
voilà donc je pense que j'ai fait à peu
près le tour de la question alors je
suis désolé de pas très positif mais le
rap en tout cas j'ai contribué il met
clairement l'idée que ben en fait on est
dans une situation qui comme très
défavorable en fait c'est à dire qu'on
l'a laissé passer le temps et le temps
qui nous reste pour pour atteindre ses
objectifs de développement durable pour
atténuer changement climatique pour
s'adapter ben il est la fenêtre elle est
en train de se fermer en fait
oui
voila merci beaucoup
sénateur de avoir posé question très
importante
donc je vous cher quelques
idées que je peux transmettre
vous avez parlé dans mon cas la pause
éducation concernant le stockage de
carbone puits de carbone
alors selon
notre rapport
ça c'est en relation avec la
géo-ingénierie donc en fait
effectivement nous n'avons pas préconisé
on n'a pas vu vraiment des résultats
positifs concernant deux de ces
techniques il n'a pas encore d avec une
technique de maudite monitoring on n'a
pas pu prouver que ce sera vraiment une
efficacité
alors l'autre question de ct par rapport
à des inondations
et donc effectivement on peut distinguer
dans les processus de prise de décisions
pour adaptation les lits méthode top
down bottom ap les méthodes car la
population va essayer de trouver des
solutions qu'est ce qu'on peut faire il
a beaucoup d'études sur ça et les
initiatives qui vient de la part des
politiciens et souvent finalement
actuellement on essaye de
justement de
travailler ensemble de ça peut être une
solution
intéressante de dom com vous avez dit la
solidarité dans les villes s'adapte
interruptus la population dans les
prises de décision
et avoir une vision plus
ouvert donc alors
[Musique]
c'était la question aussi de modèle
économique donc le giec n'a pas voulu
suivre un modèle économique classique
coûts et bénéfices dans les décisions
on a pas on a essayé d'éviter aussi de
de transformer
en termes de
monétaire
là les résultats
ddd
modification des coûts d'adaptation
justement ce qui a été évoqué par
[Musique]
grenade c'est la question de justice
climatique
donc il ya toute une éthique
de changement climatique qui doit
prendre en considération
les
les droits
intergénérationnel les droits
interrégionale et droits intérêts spes
même des animaux donc en fait et ça ce
n'est des éléments de justice climatique
et atik qui vont avoir un rôle important
dans les prises de décision
donc
bon il a plu beaucoup de questions je ne
voudrais pas prendre trop de
temps de répondre mais
peut-être il avait question quand même
deux
eco anxiété de des problèmes liés à ces
changements
qui nous attend et qui peuvent être
affreux parce qu'on essaye d'avoir
l'espoir que les fans allaient dans le
bon sens
et le giec a interdit aussi une chapitre
en fait à côté de deux chapitres de
santé il ya quelque chose aussi sur le
bien-être le bien-être donc le bien-être
de la population c'est un élément
extrêmement important dans l'est
pour le
fonctionnement de systèmes humaine et
avoir la résilience nécessaire pour
comprendre les avantages un problème
bon
je pourrais continuer quelques idées
voilà de réponse
mais masson-delmotte je vais vous
laisser répondre aux nombreuses
questions et puis peut-être
enclencher un mot de conclusion
cet échange oui merci beaucoup alors sur
le la charte fin nous traiter de la
charte de l'énergie donc c'est analyser
comme étant un traité qui a été
construit pour protéger des
investissements étrangers dans le
secteur de l'énergie mais qui conduit à
de très nombreux litiges devant des
tribunaux d'arbitrage privé souvent au
détriment des états et de leur conduite
de la transition énergétique
typiquement un des risques c'est de
protéger des actifs fossiles
potentiellement échoué donc si un état
souhaitent des commissionné plus
rapidement des infrastructures fossiles
mais ça peut être aussi un frein à des
ajustements par rapport à des
subventions sur les énergies
renouvelables quand en réalité les coûts
en diminuer et donc que les politiques
publiques évolue donc pour ces raisons
j'ai effectivement soutenu un appel à
sortir de ce traité de la charte de
l'énergie tel qu'il est construit
actuellement et vous noterez que un
certain nombre de pays en sont sortis je
crois que c'est le cas de la norvège ou
de l'italie par exemple
cela fait partie des analyses des
obstacles ou freins potentiels vous avez
abordé la question par exemple de la
prise de conscience de l'ensemble des
gens ou bien parfois d'une forme de
paralysie par rapport à de l'anxiété et
ce qui est extrêmement pertinent je
pense c'est d'analyser où sont les
obstacles et les freins par exemple le
rapport du groupe 2 dans le chapitre
europe a analysé les freins à
l'adaptation et il souligne parmi ces
freins un manque de littératie
climatique c'est-à-dire bien comprendre
les causes et les implications ancré
dans chaque contexte c'est quelque chose
qui manque encore maintenant je veux
insister sur ce volet je ne sais pas
quelle est la formation dont vous
disposez vous même comme les bus pour
bien vous prié les enjeux pas uniquement
au niveau planétaire comme on l'a fait
rapidement mes propres au contexte
français il me semble qu'il ya un
déficit de monter en compétences partout
et même les programmes de lycée qui ont
été mis en oeuvre récemment ne
permettent pas de construire ses
compétences pour les plus jeunes
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est vraiment
un effort considérable a mené dans le
secteur de l'enseignement supérieur le
rapport jouzel qui avait été rendu il ya
plusieurs mois n'a pas donné suite à la
mise en oeuvre d'actions structurantes
pour permettre de monter le socle de
compétences nécessaires même dans les
systèmes de formation initiale
le deuxième point que je voulais aborder
c'était la question de la transformation
dans le secteur agricole donc les deux
rapports 2 et 3 ans tous les deux un
chapitre dédié soit sur les enjeux
d'adaptation soit sur les enjeux de
réduire les émissions du secteur de la
production alimentaire sur toutes les
formes de production mais aussi sur
l'évolution des pratiques alimentaires
et l'augmentation possible du stockage
de carbone dans les sols et c'est le
secteur où l'enjeu est vraiment
d'arriver à articuler les deux nokia un
certain nombre de scénarios propres au
contexte français qui existe un l'inra
et solagro l'iddri le haut conseil
climat travaille actuellement un rapport
spécifique sur les enjeux pour
l'agriculture et ça souligne aussi les
enjeux à articuler le ce qui va être le
cap en fait des subventions de la
politique agricole européenne avec
l'ambition qui va être portée dans le
cadre de la stratégie française énergie
et climat
si je met l'accent sur un point c'est le
travail sur les protéines donc la
diversification des sources de protéines
pour l'alimentation humaine et le
travail sur les filières de production
de protéines en france pour
l'alimentation animale sachant que c'est
des enjeux croisés qui touche aussi à de
la déforestation importé donc et je
souligne que le rapport du groupe iii du
giec sur ces aspects là souligne la
diversité des options d'actions les
formes d'agriculture de conservation des
sols les formes d'agroécologie diverses
y compris avec une forme
d'intensification soutenable qui sont
possibles et il met en lui hier des
formes traditionnelles que la france
connaît bien de polyculture comme
faisant partie de systèmes résilient à
faible émission qui permettent de
stocker du carbone dans les sols et donc
il ya des enjeux en fait à
comment dire valoriser ses formes
d'activités agricoles
peut-être aussi en rémunérant davantage
les agriculteurs pour les services
écosystémiques qui sont apportées
après donc y avait une question qui
était posée sur les limites du rat
l'adaptation
typiquement le recul du manteau neigeux
le recul des glaciers ça va se traduire
par une baisse de l'approvisionnement en
eau pendant les saisons sèches ça
concerne le sud de la france directement
pour un réchauffement de l'ordre de 2
degrés autour de 2050 ça peut être des
limites dur typiquement 20%
d'approvisionnement en eau en moins et
cela souligne l'importance pour la
gestion de l'eau ne pas simplement
mettre en place des rustines c'est à
dire un petit stockage d'eau temporaires
qui permet de conserver les pratiques à
l'identique mais d'essayer de chercher
des ruptures pour être beaucoup plus
résilient par la suite sur la gestion
intégrée de l'eau pour les écosystèmes
et pour les besoins des sociétés
humaines il ya une question qui a porté
sur finalement le contexte actuel les
chocs les crises et la capacité à tenir
le cap c'est vraiment très clairement
illustré dans les rapports 2 et 3 sous
forme de graphique qui montre en fait
plein de point de bifurcation de
décision donc c'est point de bifurcation
ça peut être une pandémie et la relance
c'est à dire 'est-ce qu'on relance les
secteurs très émetteurs ou est-ce qu'on
accélère les transformations ça peut
être un conflit géopolitique est ce qu
on utilise l'enjeu d'indépendance
énergétique pour agir sur la demande
pour chercher à avoir un système
énergétique décarbonés donc sortant plus
rapidement des énergies fossiles ou
est-ce qu'au contraire on essaie de
diversifier les approvisionnements
fossiles au risque de verrouiller par
des investissements des infrastructures
et maîtrise et de la même manière quand
on est affectée par des événements
extrêmes est-ce qu'on reconstruit à
l'identique moi je les ai vus faire sur
le littoral français après des tempêtes
ou est ce que on se projette sur la
durée de vie de l'infrastructure et
est-ce qu'on se protège est ce qu'on se
est ce qu'on prévoit davantage des
replis stratégiques de sorte à vraiment
renforcer la résilience voilà donc je
pense qu'en fait en permanence vous êtes
confrontés à ces point de décision c'est
point de bifurcation et la question est
de savoir comment construire
collectivement une possibilité à chaque
fois de renforcer la résilience et de
contribuer à la baisse des émissions pas
sûr de l'immédiat mais vraiment des
choses structurels à long terme il ya un
point qui n'a pas été mentionné c'est
sous l'angle purement économique dans le
rapport du groupe iii sur les
trajectoires largement en dessous de
deux degrés ou un degré et demi le
montant des investissements ça
représente au niveau mondial
0,05 à 0 15 % du pib chaque année
donc le rapport souligne qu'il existe
des liquidités des capitaux disponibles
et il ya un enjeu qui est de créer les
conditions de la confiance c'est à dire
avec un cap clair qui permet de
mobiliser en fait à ses ressources
disponibles et en particulier l'épargné
des particuliers qui est pas
complètement mobilisée pour pouvoir
investir sachant que si j'ai bien
compris purement d'un point de vue
macroéconomique agir plus tôt c'est
bénéfique c'est à dire ça crée les
conditions d'une économie bas carbone
d'emploi etc et l'autre volet c'est que
les bénéfices rien qu'en terme de
qualité de l'air améliorer peuvent être
supérieurs au coût des investissements
nécessaires et je vais revenir sur la
partie bénéfices donc vous l'avez
compris le rapport du groupe iii en
particulier soulignant les enjeux de
transition juste c'est-à-dire tenir
compte des vulnérabilités apporter un
accompagnement aux plus fragiles que ce
soit par rapport à la précarité
énergétique ou que ce soit par rapport
aux reconversions nécessaires et elles
vont être massives 1 ne serait ce que
dans le secteur de l'automobile par
exemple donc ces enjeux de transition
justice ont souligné comme pouvant bien
fonctionné si les individus dans leur
cadre personnel ou professionnel
voit une amélioration de leur bien-être
c'est vraiment un des conditions clés
pour qu' il ya un soutien en fait un
engagement sur des transformations
structurelles et donc la question qui
était posée était
qu'est-ce qu'on mettra en priorité je
pense que les leviers actions qui
permettent d'améliorer
le bien-être la santé c'est quelque
chose qui peut être un facteur
d'engagement de manière rapide donc ça
touche à l'évolution a fait des
pratiques alimentaires
pour valoriser une alimentation
nutritive scène et soutenable les
mobilités active un très clairement y
compris par rapport aux enjeux de santé
mentale le fait de bouger davantage
ça apporte de multiples bénéfices c'est
parce qu'on valorise aujourd'hui non
dans les trajets ne serait ce que pour
aller à l'école pour les plus jeunes
près de nous à la suisse l'allemagne
l'autriche les pays-bas le danemark dans
des conditions même plus rigoureuse
par rapport à la tension qui est portée
aux plus jeunes beaucoup d'écoles
d'établissements scolaires sont
construits en zone inondable
ça a conduit à des discontinuités
d'accès à l'école on a vu avec des
vagues de chaleur de plus en plus
précoces juin 2019 le brevet retarder la
au moment du bac la question majeure
d'adaptation des établissements
scolaires pour fonctionner correctement
dans un climat plus chaud et vous posiez
la question de l'inquiétude des plus
jeunes ou leur désengagement de la vie
publique
mais mettre en priorité les droits des
enfants en fait apporté une attention
plus forte pour améliorer aussi leurs
conditions d'études de vie créer des
espaces des changes à notre place faire
venir aussi les mouvements de jeunesse
par exemple
sur l'événement qui a été organisé
devant les députés ça a été co organisé
avec les étudiants du manifeste et
étudiants pour la transition écologique
ce sont des étudiants qui sont très
motivés pour eux-mêmes acquérir des
compétences et contribuer à la réflexion
je les vois participé à des comités de
parties prenantes de grandes entreprises
je pense que ça mériterait d'être
renforcée pour ne pas qu'ils aient cette
espèce de clivage ou de risque sur la
cohésion sociale et le dernier point
peut-être je sais pas si c'était
vraiment dit mais il ya vraiment ce
besoin de construire une vision partagée
ça a été dit sur les côtes écrivant
je ne sais pas en fait comment on
pourrait rapprocher les communautés
scientifiques dont quelques
représentants étaient présents dans le
monde académique
de vos besoins mais il ya certainement
des choses qui pourraient être
construites renforcer sur des espaces
des changes recueillir des
questionnements spécifiques et voir
quelles peuvent être les besoins de
production de co production de
connaissances de sorte à mieux répondre
à ses besoins c'est un point qui me
tient à coeur parce que souvent ce que
je vois c'est des recours par exemple à
des cabinets conseils même sur des plans
d'action territoriaux à l'échelle de
ville ou au niveau national alors qu'il
ya des compétences et des ressources
qu'on peut mobiliser des personnes qui
sont présentes dans les centres de
recherche dans les universités qui ne
demandent qu'une chose en fait ans et
être davantage mobilisés pour produire
des connaissances qui soient pertinentes
qui soient utiles et le cadre pour cela
n'existe pas nécessairement et puis le
dernier volet c'est la possibilité
certainement d'utiliser mieux la
télévision les médias audiovisuels
publics pour montrer comment agir c'est
à dire comment construire un style de
vie avec une empreinte légère comment
par exemple le rénover un logement de
manière performante avec des systèmes de
chauffage bas carbone c'est pas les
systèmes de chauffage au gaz ans est
vraiment les systèmes de pompes à
chaleur ou autres associés à des
rénovations il n'y a pas en fait un de
ressources disponibles on voit comment
des cours et pour revendre n'en vois pas
comment gagner sur l'efficacité
énergétique la performance d'un logement
même chose sur l'alimentation même chose
sur les transports je pense qu'en fait
le les leviers d'action de l'audiovisuel
public sont pas mobilisés au sens de
apporter des éléments factuels des
retours d'expérience pour montrer
comment on peut agir comment on peut
gagner en confort en bien-être et les
personnes dont le chauffage est très
réduit les personnes qui ont décarbonés
leur mobilité n'ont pas l'inquiétude
actuellement par rapport aux prix des
énergies fossiles
donc c'est aussi quelque chose qui
améliore le bien être indirectement idem
dans les entreprises et je pense que
c'est pas encore suffisamment montré
pour permettre de se projeter dans ces
transformations de sorte à les réussir
et avoir envie d'agir voilà c'est ce que
je voulais partager avec vous
sincèrement je tiens mesdames et
mesdames messieurs à vous remercier pour
votre votre présentation et
présentations qualité pour pour le
travail que vous réalisez et le travail
que vous avez réalisé jusqu'à maintenant
pour la clarté de vos propos
pour vos analyses analyse performante et
analyses pertinentes
il est effectivement important d'alerter
sur cette problématique liée au climat
mais et de effectivement d'avoir un
message qui puisse à un moment donné
alerter mais moi comme didier mandelli
je pense qu'il faut effectivement
délivrer un message d'espoir parce que
si on veut y arriver il faut aussi que
nous ne fassions pas que du
catastrophisme parce que on ne
mobilisera pas des gens en leur
expliquant que n'importe comment même si
on fait quelque chose qui était pas on
n'y arrivera pas et ça marchera pas et
donc je crois qu'il faut délivrer ce
message positif je tiens à remercier
tous mes collègues tous mes collègues
qui ont assisté à cette audition
effectivement nous étions nombreux parce
qu'il y avait et je remercie encore le
présent marché il y avait beaucoup de
deux collègues qui ne font pas partie de
la commission d'aménagement du
territoire qui étaient soit en
présentiel soit en visio et ce malgré
que le mercredi 1 est consacrée aux
réunions commission et il y avait des
réunions commission aujourd'hui avec des
ordres du jour important avec des
auditions aussi et et moi je les
remercie parce que ça montre tout
l'intérêt que portent les sénateurs
sueur sur ce sujet et l'envi de chacune
et chacun d'entre nous un d'essayer
d'apporter sa pierre à l'édifice et on
doit vous remercier pour effectivement
et bien
le travail que vous faites
et vous pourrez compter sur sur le sénat
et sur le travail que nous allons
entreprendre et que nous voulons
entreprendre c'est pas pour nous
entreprenons c'est pour les générations
à venir c'est pour effectivement sauver
notre planète et jeu mais je vous
remercie vraiment de votre engagement et
je pense que cette audition était
particulièrement bénéfique et je tiens à
remercier mes collègues qui sont ne sont
pas membres de la commission
d'aménagement du territoire du
développement durable pour leur présenta
remercie bien sûr mes collègues de la
commission d'aménagement du territoire
et du développement durable qui sont
mobilisés chaque jour et d'ailleurs je
leur demanderai de rester encore
quelques minutes parce que il ya un
autre point d'ordre du jour mais qui est
qui va être très rapide
dont je souhaite vous donner
l'information et d'ailleurs on n'est pas
trop en retard parce que si vous
regardez la pendule de droite n'est que
11h03 donc donc on a encore un peu de
temps devant nous voilà merci chers
collègues